GOOD
AFTERNOON. I AM CALLING THIS
JOINT HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION AND SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEES TO ORDER WHAT I
START JUST BY GIVING A WELCOME-
TO YOU BECAUSE I'VE READ MY
STATEMENT HERE THAT SOMEONE
TOOK THE TIME TO READ UP A GOOD
AFTERNOON IT IS A MY PLEASURE
TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE-
FIRST. EDUCATION COMMITTEE
HEARING OF TWENTY TWENTY FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING THIS YEAR-
THIS AFTERNOON THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEES ARE
HOLDING OUR ANNUAL JOINT
HEARING. TO HEAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. OF
STUDENT COUNCILS THAT'S AN
ORGANIZATION I'M SOMEWHAT
FAMILIAR WITH BECAUSE MY SISTER
Là ACTUALLY VOLUNTEERS TIME
WITH IT. THANK YOU ALSO AND
ACTUALLY GOT STUCK AN ALLEY ON
A PLANE BECAUSE OF THE FOG AND
COULDN'T COME IN TO JOIN YOU
TODAY. SO SHE MAKES ME WELL
AWARE OF YOUR VENTURES AND YOUR
ADVENTURES. THE STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATE THE STUDENT
ADVISORY BOARD ON LEGISLATION
EDUCATION AND WORK VERY HARD.
TO IDENTIFY PROBLEMS RESEARCH
ISSUES AND DEVELOP LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS REPRESENTATIVES. OF
THIS ADVISORY BOARD WILL
PRESENT LEGISLATIVE.
LEGISLATIONS LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS TO US THIS AFTERNOON.
THE PROPOSALS PRESENTED AT THIS
HEARING THERE SOMETIME SO
COMPELLING SOMETIME SO
COMPELLING THAT THEIR INJURIES
IS ACTUAL LEGISLATION IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. OUR I AM
PREACHERS STUDENTS HARD WORK
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM THE FROM THEIR IDEAS TO
IMPROVE- CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM CENTER LEYVA
IS ALSO HERE TODAY ALL TURN THE
MIKE OVER TO HER SHORTLY- BUT
WITH OTHER MEMBERS WILL COME
AND GO- AND I'LL TURN THE MIKE
OVER TO THEM IN JUST A MINUTE-
IS JUST SO THEY CAN INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES SOME WILL BE COMING
GOING WE'LL GIVE THEM TIME TO
SAY ANYTHING BECAUSE THEY'RE
COMING AND GOING BUT EITHER WAY
I WOULD LIKE TO CALL A READ
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA'S US.
I HAVE A SENATOR SPEAK BEFORE I
DO THAT. BUT EITHER WAY JUST SO
YOU KNOW SO YOU KNOW MY KNEES
PATRICK O'DONNELL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FROM THE SEVENTY THE
SENATE DISTRICT. THAT'S LONG
BEACH SIGNAL HILL SAMPEDRO AND
CATALINA ISLAND IS ANYBODY FROM
THOSE AREAS. OKAY WELL THAT'S
WHERE I'M FROM. I REPRESENT
THAT AREA AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
TO BE HERE TODAY FOR ONE
PARTICULAR REASON AND THAT I'M
A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER BY TRADE.
YEAH I WAS BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM A LITTLE BIT THIS
FALL I GO BACK AND SUB A LITTLE
BIT- WHEN WE'RE NOT UP IN
SACRAMENTO THERE'S A TIME OF
THE YEAR OR NOT UP IN
SACRAMENTO MUCH OF THAT IS JUST
ADDED. SO BASICALLY OUR YARD WE
HAVE LIKE A SCHOOL YEAR THAT
STARTS IN JANUARY ENDS IN
SEPTEMBER- AND I CHAIR THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE. SO ALL BILLS AS
WE KNOW START WITH AN IDEA GET
A BILL NUMBER. GO TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND TO KEEP
IT SHORT OF THE FULL BODY ON
THE FLOOR. AND THEN GO TO THE
OTHER HOUSE. TO KEEP IT SIMPLE.
ARE WHITE. THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE ON MY HANDS ARE ON A
LOT OF LEGISLATION IT AND- I'M
I HAVE A PRETTY STRONG OPINION
ABOUT. EDUCATION YOU MIGHT EVEN
HEAR SOME OF IT TO. OUR IN THE
KNEES DEPORTED GREAT
FINANCIALLY FOR. BUT ALSO
SHOULDN'T MANAGE THE CLASS.
FROM SACRAMENTO I'M BIG ON
MAKING SURE YOU PASSED ON A
MANDATE IT IS A WISE MANDATE
MEANING WE'RE TELLING THEM.
EXACTLY WHAT THEY DO.
SACRAMENTO DOESN'T ALWAYS KNOW
BEST. ABA YOU DO BECAUSE YOU
ARE ASSN ROUND CALIFORNIA AND I
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
ALL THIS BEEN A GREAT
EXPERIENCE. I RAN INTO A COUPLE
ON THE ELEVATOR YESTERDAY AND I
WAS HAPPY TO GIVE YOU A QUICK
TO A- BASEMENT. BECAUSE I'M
GONNA WAS MOST YOU. SEE ON YOUR
ON YOUR TOUR THAT IN THE
BASEMENT. NOTICES THE BASEMENT
AND NOW. HE'S SO I'M PRETTY
ROLLICKING PLACE. WITH THAT I'M
GONNA CHECK IT OVER. SENATOR
LEYVA TO GIVE WELCOME. THANK
YOU SO MY MEMBER. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M CONNIE LEIVA I AM
THE SENATOR FOR THE TWENTY A
SENATE DSTRICT. PRESENTING
POMONA AL DECEMBER DINO IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. AND I'M ALSO THE
CHAIR OF SENATE EDUCATION. AND
I LOVE THIS TIME OF YEAR-
BEFORE I WAS THE CHAIR OF ST ED
I'VE SAT ON SENATE EDUCATION
SINCE I WAS ELECTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. AND I LOVE
HEARING YOUR IDEAS. YOU ARE ALL
VERY BRIGHT YOU ARE OUR FUTURE
YOU ALWAYS GIVE ME HOPE FOR THE
FUTURE. YOU BRING US
LEGISLATIVE IDEAS- TWO OF WHICH
I HAVE AUTHORED AND HAVE BEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW SO GOOD JOB- SO
TODAY REALLY I JUST AND EXCITED
TO HEAR WHAT YOU BRING TO US I
APOLOGIZE AT ALL HAVE TO DIP
OUT. AS I THINK CENTER DRAWS A
WILL FOR A MINUTE BECAUSE WE
ARE IN AT. HEALTH COMMITTEE AS
WELL RIGHT NOW WITH THE VOTE-
BUT I REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR IDEAS AND I THINK
YOU FOR THE TIME. AND EFFORT
YOU PUT INTO. BRINGING THEM TO
US SO. SB SHORTS WE GET STARTED.
SENATOR RUSSELL DID YOU PUSH TO.
ADD ANYTHING. YES HI MY NAME IS
MY DILEMMA THAT ALSO AND I AM
THE SENATOR REPRESENTING
DISTRICTS SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS PRIMARILY
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND THE
COUNTY EAST LA IN THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES I DON'T THINK ANY
OF THE SCHOOLS HERE ARE IN THE
DISTRICT BUT WELCOME ANYWAY-
I'M IN MY SECOND YEAR AS A
STATE SENATOR. SO I'M A
SOPHOMORE. HERE AND I SAT
THROUGH YOUR PRESENTATIONS LAST
YEAR AND IT'S VERY VERY- IT'S
REALLY GREAT TO HEAR YOUR
IDEAS. HOW YOU PREPARE- YOUR
IDEAS THE SERIOUSNESS WITH
WHICH YOU TAKE THEM GREAT GREAT
IDEA SO I LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
HERE AND- ON LISTEN TO YOUR
PRESENTATIONS AND SEEN OUR NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS. RIGHT
BEFORE MY VERY EYES. GREAT
THANK YOU AND AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER SOME CENTERS AND SOME
YOURS WILL COMING GOING THAT'S
TYPICAL DURING HEARING. BECAUSE
THERE MIGHT BE TWO HEARINGS
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE AT THE SAME
TIME WHAT YOU DO IS YOU JUST GO
OFF TAKE OFF YOU COME BACK AND
VOTE AND IT'S NOT IT'S NOT OF
NORMAL TO SEE SOME NOT PRESENT.
SOME WALKING IN AND OUT THAT'S
VERY VERY TYPICAL AND I SHOULD
JUST KNOW WE HAVE STAFF HERE TO
THE FOLKS THE RAISE OUR HNDS-
THEY ARE REALLY THE BRAINS OF
THIS OPERATION THERE THE POLICY
EXPERTS- THESE FOLKS HAVE MANY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AND
EDUCATION POLICY WHICH IS A
VERY TECHNICAL ISSUE. THE
ENCODE IS VERY HIGH- A LOT OF
BILLS A LOT OF IDEAS I HAVE
BEEN PUT IN AND YOU KNOW. IN
THE STATUTE- THAT. ACTUALLY YOU
KNOW CAME THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
AND THESE ARE THE FOLKS THAT
KNOW THOSE AND THESE ARE THE
FOLKS WE RELY ON. THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR TO HELP US MAKE
DECISIONS HELP GUIDE US TO MAKE
SURE SHE ONE OF THE IMPACTS OF
THIS BILL. AND WHEN YOU COME UP
BE RESENT SOMETIME OF A MOVING
ALONG DON'T DON'T DON'T TAKE
OFFENSE BUT- OFTEN TIMES THERE
ARE TIMES ALL HAVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BILLS AND ONE DAY.
THAT I HAVE TO HEAR. AND WE CAN
HAVE A TWELVE HOUR HEARING.
UNLESS I KIND OF MOVING ALONG
SO SOMETIMES IF YOU SEE ME
DOING THAT IT'S NOT PERSONAL.
IT'S ACTUALLY JUST KIND OF
PROFESSIONAL SO WE KEEP THINGS
MOVING BECAUSE WE- WANT TO HAVE
A TWELVE ARE HEARING TODAY. I
THINK AS WELL- WITH THAT. GOING
TO CALL UP BY EIGHT THREE
REPEAT PRESIDENT. OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S OPENNESS. COUNCIL
AND IS. THAT WOULD LIKE TO. GO.
ALL SCHOOL AND RUN OUR ARC-
SOME OPENING REMARKS AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA. GET TO WORK. FEET
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE SHARES
SENATOR LEYVA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DONALD ESTEEMED MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES AND EDUCATION AND TO
GUESTS MY NAME IS A RE READ I'M
A SENIOR CREE TO HIGH SCHOOL IN
ONE APART CALIFORNIA. AND I
SERVICE THE STATE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS OR TASK. AND
THIS YEAR'S DOING ADVISORY
BOARD ON LEGISLATION AND
EDUCATION OR SABLE HAS BROUGHT
TOGETHER STUDENTS FROM ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO PRESENT
AND REPRESENT THE STUDENT VOICE
THESE STUDENT PRESENTATIONS
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
WITHOUT SEVERAL THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM. I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMEND ASSEMBLY CHIEF
CONSULTANT HUNG IN LIEBERMAN
AND SENATE CHIEF CONSULTANT
LYNN LORBER FOR NOT ONLY MAKING
THIS DURING HEARING SYBIL BUT
ALL FOR ATTENDING OUR TRIM
PANEL LAST NIGHT AT. STUDENT
THE PROFESSIONAL. INSIGHT THAN
RICH THE PROPOSAL'S YOU WILL
HEAR FROM SHORTLY. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY IS
UNPARALLELED THE SOLUTIONS YOU
WILL HEAR FROM OUR INSIGHTFUL
AND INNOVATIVE THEY REPRESENT
THE TENACITY AND PASSION OF
STUDENTS FOR ACROSS THE STATE.
AND CONVEY THE URGENCY OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE PROPOSALS WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO I WILL PASS IT OVER
pDIRECTOR ISAAC A MINERAL. FOR
MORE ON TODAY'S PRESENTATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
TEARS LEYVA AND O'DONNELL AND
HIS TEAM MEMBERS OF BOTH THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
ON EDUCATION MY NAME IS AS A
CAMARO AND I AM A STUDENT AT
HIGH TECH HIGH. IN THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AT THE EDUCATION POLICY
DIRECTOR TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT
COUNCILS. AND THE IT'S AN
ADVISORY BOARD ON LEGISLATION
IN EDUCATION CONFERENCE DR
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS STABLE. THE
DELEGATES BEHIND ME ARE A
STRONG WORK WELL TO CRITICAL
THINKERS WHO ARE PERCEPTIVE AND
PASSIONATE ABOUT THEIR
EDUCATION. THEIR DESIRE TO
ACTIVELY WORK FOR CHANGE WITHIN
OUR CALIFORNIA EDUCATION SYSTEM
INSPIRES NOT ONLY ME BUT THE
REST OF MY STUFF AS WELL. WITH
NO BY SOME STAFF MEMBERS THIS
YEAR'S DELEGATES DEBATED VOTED
AND DECIDED ON SIX TO SING
TOPICS. ENVIRONMENT SCHOOL
SAFETY MENTAL HEALTH MINORITY
STUDENTS SUPPORT. POSITIVE
DISCIPLINARY PRACTICES IN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATIVE POLICY
COMMITTEE OF THE CALIFORNIA
FISH IN A STUDENT COUNCILS. HAS
DEVELOPED A PROPOSAL CALL THE
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT ACT. THE
DELEGATES BEHIND ME BOTH
UNDERSTAND AND ACKNOWLEDGE IT
THIS IS BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL
POLICY IDEAS. AND I'VE GOT THIS
IN MIND WHEN EVALUATING ALL
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THE STUDENT
ADVISORY BOARD ON LEGISLATION
AND EDUCATION FOR THIS YOU
PROPOSALS THAT ABOUT THE ISSUES
WITHIN ACTON TURNING
ENVIRONMENT SCHOOL SAFETY OF
MENTAL HEALTH. MINORITY SUPPORT
POSITIVE DISCIPLINARY PRACTICES
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IN THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH COMMISSION. I
WOULD LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN THANK
ASSEMBLY CHIEF CONSULTANT TANYA
LIEBERMAN AND SENATE CHIEF
CONSULTANT LYNN LEVER FOR
MAKING THIS JOINT HEARING
POSSIBLE AND ATTENDING ARE
DRIVING PANEL LAST NIGHT. ALL
THE WHILE GIVING VALUABLE
FEEDBACK THAT IS HELPED US MAKE
OUR PROPOSALS AS PROFESSIONAL
IN FEASIBLE AS POSSIBLE. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE SIX FOR POSES
THAT WE PRESENT TO YOU TODAY A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CONCERNS
FROM STUDENTS ALL ACROSS STATE.
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU- WHY
DON'T WE HAVE OUR- FIRST PANEL
WHICH IS. NOW IT'S ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. IT'S ALL OF
FRENCH- AYE AYE I'M GONNA HAVE
YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELVES I'M
GONNA DO THAT. THERE. SO COME
ON UP TO THE WHAT WE DO ON A
REGULAR COMEY THIS VERY MUCH
LIKE A REGULAR HEARING WHERE WE
HAVE YOU COME UP AND PRESENT
YOUR BILL IDEA- TYPICALLY WHAT
WE ALSO HAVE AS OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT MAYBE SOME LOBBYIST
WOULD BE SITTING OVER HER TO
FURTHER EXPLAIN THE BILL MORE
TECHNICAL TERMS AND AFTER YOU
WOULD SPEAK TYPICALLY. WHAT WE
CALL THE OPPOSITION THIS
BUSINESS YOU GOTTA BE ABLE. TO
LOOK YOUR OPPOSITION IN THE
FACE AND YOU KNOW GO AGAINST
HIM AND ALSO. STILL WORK WITH
THEM. ANNA IT'S NOT JUST ALL.
WHAT THEY DO AND YOU SEE IF YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN. SO WITH THAT-
WHEN WE HAVE OUR FIRST
PRESENTER INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND YOU MAY START MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF. AN
ESTEEMED SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RILEY MORE
AT AND I'M A SENIOR AT GRANADA
HIGH SCHOOL. I AM ALSO THE
STUDENT BOARD REPRESENTATIVE ON
THE LIVER MORE JOINT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. OF ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SIXTEEN AND SENATE
DISTRICT SEVEN. MY NAME IS LIZ
HIS RODRIGUEZ I AM A SENIOR
KERR IN HIGH SCHOOL AND THE
STUDENT BORDER PRESENTED A FOR
THE CRIME UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. TO ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THIRTY ONE AND SENATE DISTRICT
TWELVE. MY NAME IS OLIVER
FRENCH I'M A JUNIOR AT CREDO
HIGH IN THE COULD HADI VOTER
PARK UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. I
AM REPRESENTING ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOUR AND SENATE
DISTRICT TO. AS INVOLVED MEMBER
OF MY STUDENT COUNCIL AND
SUPPORTER OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY SPECIFICALLY IN
SCHOOLS. I AM GRATEFUL TO BE
HERE AND LIKE TO THANK THE
STEAM TO SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR PROVIDING THIS
PLATFORM FOR STUDENTS TO USE
THEIR VOICE. AND SPEAK UP IN
TODAY'S POLITICAL CLIMATE IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER FOR
THE CITIZENS TO SPEAK UP AND
FIGHT FOR WHAT THEY BELIEVE
AND- THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE
TODAY. TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
CLIMATE CRISIS AND TO FIGHT FOR
A BETTER FUTURE. ACCORDING TO
THE WORLD METEOROLOGICAL
ORGANIZATION SEE LEVELS
CONTINUE TO RISE. WILD FIRES IN
HER TEENS HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY MORE INTENSE AND
OUR PLAN IS ONLY GETTING HOTTER.
AS SEEN IN COUNTLESS CLIMATE
STRIKES AND MARCHES ACROSS THE
GLOBE PEOPLE ARE DEMANDING
SUBSTANTIAL STRUCTURAL CHANGE
NOTABLY. OUR GENERATION OF
STUDENTS HAVE MOBILIZED AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE OFTENTIMES
SHOWING MORE PASSION FOR THE
ISSUE THEN THE ELECTED MEMBERS
OF THEIR GOVERNMENTS. ON MARCH
FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
OVER A MILLION STUDENTS
WORLDWIDE WALKED OUT OF THEIR
SCHOOLS IN PROTEST. WITH THIS
MUCH ACTIVISM COMING FROM THE
YOUTH ONE WOULD THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE REFLECTED IN THE
SCHOOLS. BUT CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
ARE DOING LITTLE TO PROMOTE OR
ENSURE ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY. AS A RESULT IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE EXPERIENCED
THE EFFECTS OF THE CLIMATE
CRISIS FIRSTHAND DROUGHT TO
MADE WATER CONSERVATION MORE
VITAL THAN EVER. AND WILD FIRES
HAVE SWEPT ACROSS OUR STATE
CAUSING IMMEASURABLE DAMAGE. TO
HOMES BUSINESSES AND FAMILIES.
I MYSELF HAVE BEEN EVACUATED
BECAUSE OF THE FIRES. AND IT'S
A SCARY FEELING NOT KNOWING IF
I CAN COME HOME. MY SCHOOL IS
ALSO BEEN SHUT DOWN FOR DAYS AT
A TIME. DUE TO POOR AIR QUALITY.
BECAUSE DURING THE FIRE SEASON
WHEN THE GRASS IS DRY AND THE
WINDS ARE UNUSUALLY STRONG. I
LIVE IN FEAR. MY FAMILY LIVES
IN FEAR. MY FRIENDS WHO HAVE
ALREADY LOST THEIR HOMES LIVE
IN FEAR. BUT I REFUSED TO LET
THIS CONTINUE SO I'M HERE. I'M
FIGHTING FOR CHANGE. OUR
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THIS CLIMATE CRISIS
THROUGH THE EXISTING FUNDS.
SUPPLIED BY THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD EVERY YEAR THE
STATE ALLOCATION BOARD
DISTRIBUTE 86% OF ITS FUNDING
TO THE MODERNIZATION AND
CONSTRUCTION OF SCHOOL
FACILITIES FAST WE PROPOSE THE
GOVERNING BOARDS OF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO APPLY FOR FUNDING.
THROUGH THE STATE ALLOCATION
BOARD FOR A SCHOOL
MODERNIZATION PROJECT OR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT AFTER THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE MUST AS
A PART OF THE SUBSEQUENT
MODERNIZATIONS OR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT INCLUDE LOW FLOW WATER
AERATORS AND LED LIGHTS. WATER
AERATORS ARE THE SMALL METAL
PARTS PLACED ON THE END OF
FAUCETS THAT LOOK LIKE MESH
SCREENS WATER AERATORS BREAK UP
THE FLOW OF WATER INTO MULTIPLE
SMALL STREAMS ADDING AIR IN
BETWEEN WHICH ULTIMATELY
REDUCES WATER USAGE WITHOUT
ACTUALLY AFFECTING THE WATER
SURE. CURRENTLY THE MAJORITY OF
FAUCETS CONTAIN AERATORS IS TWO
POINT TWO GALLONS OF WATER PER
MINUTE. LOW FLOW WATER AIRDATE
AERATORS WOULD BE THOSE
CHARACTERIZED. AS THE ONES THAT
ONLY USE ABOUT POINT FIVE TWO
ONE GALLONS GALLONS OF WATER
PER MINUTE. THESE TOOLS ARE
BOTH BENEFICIAL AND LOW COST AS
THE AVERAGE AERATOR IS ONLY ONE
DOLLAR ACCORDING TO THE HOME
WATER WORKS ORGANIZATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF LED LIGHTS IS ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT BUT RELATIVELY LOW
COST SUSTAINABILITY PROJECT.
LED LIGHTS YOU 75% LESS ENERGY
AND THEY LASTS TWENTY FIVE
TIMES LONGER THAN TRADITIONAL
FLUORESCENT BULBS. WHILE THE
INITIAL COST OF INSTALLING LED
LIGHTS IS RELATIVELY
SUBSTANTIAL IT IS A SIZEABLE
LONG TERM INVESTMENT. THIS
PROPOSAL IS A DIRECT PATH FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS TO INCREASE
THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN COMBATING
THE CLIMATE CRISIS WITHOUT
DEMANDING ANY NEW FUNDING
PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY THIS
LEGISLATIVE APPROACH TO THE
ADDRESS TO ADJUSTING THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARDS FUNDING
GUIDELINES IS NOT UNPRECEDENTED.
THIS PROPOSAL WAS BASED IN PART
ON ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWO ZERO
FIVE WHICH WAS AUTHORED BY
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL. AND
APPROVED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWO ZERO
FIVE PURSUED THE SAME STRATEGY
BUT FOR ACQUIRING PREVENTATIVE
ACTOR SHOOTER ACTIVE SHOOTER
DOOR LOCKS. IN ADDITION
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY EIGHT FOUR
TWENTY TWENTY ALSO AUTHORED BY
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AUTHORIZED
BUT DID NOT REQUIRE THE USE OF
MODERNIZATION AND CONSTRUCTION
FOR. ON OURS ALTERNATIVE SCHOOL
SAFETY PROJECTS. BOTH SEEKING
FUNDING OPTIONS FOR THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY
PROJECTS WE HAVE BEEN LIMITED
IN BUILDING A PATH TO
COMPREHENSIVE CLIMATE ACTION
AND IMPLEMENTING CLIMATE
JUSTICE OUR PROPOSAL IS A STEP
TOWARDS MEETING THESE GOALS I'M
ALL TOO MANY CREATE IMMEDIATE
AND FORESEEABLE RESULTS. BUT IT
IS NOT NEARLY ENOUGH TO ADDRESS
AND RESOLVE THE EXTENSIVE
AFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE SB
FORMULATED THE OUTLINE FOR A
PROPOSAL WE FIRST DEVELOPED A
STRATEGY TO LEGISLATIVE THE
MANDATE FUNDING FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY
PROJECTS. HOWEVER IT CAME TO
OUR ATTENTION THAT THE STATE
COULD NOT DIRECTLY IMPORTS
FUNDING RESTRICTIONS ON THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR STATE.
THEN WE LOOKING TO AMENDING THE
LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN BUT WE
REALIZE THAT IT IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO CHANGE ITS CURRENT
FORMATTING ALSO WE WERE
INFORMED OF THE ORGANIZATION
LEADERSHIP IN ENERGY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL DESIGN
CERTIFICATION BUT VERY FEW
SCHOOLS ARE CERTIFIED DO NOT
CALL LIST. SO OFTEN WE HAVE
ADDRESSED TO CHU WAS BY MET
THESE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
MODERNIZATION I NEW
CONSTRUCTION GRANTS PROVIDED
THE LOCATION BOARD. WE WANT TO
EXPLICITLY EXPRESSED THE FACT
THE INCREMENTAL CHANGE IS NOT
FEASIBLE IN SUBSTANTIALLY
DIMINISHING THE DRASTIC
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
ACCORDING TO THE UNITED NATIONS
INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL ON
CLIMATE CHANGE REPORT WE MUST
RECTIFIER LOCK OF ENVIRONMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BY THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY. IF WE DO NOT DO
EVERYTHING TO REVERSE THE
REPERCUSSIONS WE WILL REST
SETTING OFF IRREVERSIBLE CHAIN
REACTIONS BEYOND HUMAN CONTROL.
AS HUMANS WE MUST SECURE OUR
SURVIVAL. AND ITS PERFORMANCE
WE MUST TAKE THE NECESSARY. UPS
FORCED INTO THE DIRECTION OUR
PROPOSAL IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR SCHOOLS IMPROVE
THEIR SUSTAINABILITY EFFORTS
BUT IT IS STILL NOT ENOUGH TO
FULLY RESOLVE THE CLIMATE
CRISIS WE AS YOUTH WHO HAVE TO
LIVE THROUGH THE CLIMATE CRISIS
NEED YOU TO UNDERSERVED
UNDERSTAND THE MONUMENTAL
GRAVITY AND URGENCY OF THE
ISSUE. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
TAKE BOLD PROGRESSIVE ACTION ON
ALL FRONTS TO BUILD A FUTURE
THAT IS BOTH SAFE AND
SUSTAINABLE FOR ALL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME WE ARE NOT OPEN
TO ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS GREAT THANK YOU WILL
VERY WELL DONE VERY WELL
PRESENTED FOR SURE VERY WILL
RESEARCH THE THANK YOU FOR
THAT- I JUST HAVE A FEW.
QUESTIONS INCOME ALL
INTERMINGLED THEM- I APPRECIATE
THE REALLY DUG INTO THE WEEDS
HERE TALK ABOUT THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD BECAUSE I
IMAGINE YOU COULD FIND A LOT OF
LEGISLATORS IN THIS BUILDING
WHO DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
STATE ALLOCATION BORDERS- BUT
THAT'S A BOARD I SAID ON
ACTUALLY- SO I HAVE A SPECIFIC
INTEREST IN SCHOOL FACILITIES
HAVING BEEN A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER FOR A LONG TIME IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL. I SAID SO YOU'RE
ASKING FOR MONEY FROM THE STATE
ALLOCATION WAS THAT CORRECT.
I'M WHAT WE'RE ASKING TO DO IS
THAT- WHEN PEOPLE RECEIVE THE
GRANT FROM THE STATE ALLOCATION
BOARD THEY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
USE A PORTION OF THAT GRANT
MONEY ON LED LIGHTS. AND WATER
AERATORS OKAY. OKAY I AND I
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BETTER NOW-
IT LED LIGHTS A WATER AREAS
WHERE THERE ANYTHING ELSE YOU
WANTED TO ADD. I KNOW THOSE FOR
THE TO SUSTAINABILITY PROJECTS
THAT WERE A LOW COST BUT ALSO
SEEM TO BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
OKAY I UNDERSTAND. THANK YOU
SENATOR. IT SOUNDS YOU DID A
GREAT PRESENTATION- IT SOUNDS
TOO GOOD. FOR YOU KNOW NOBODY
TO OBJECT TO. WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY IS YOUR OPPOSITION'S
STRONGEST ARGUMENT WHAT SHOULD
WE BE READY FOR. THAT COULD BE.
VOICE TO YOU AND SAY NO WE
CAN'T DO IT FOR THIS REASON
WHAT'S THE STRONGEST OPPOSITION
ARGUMENT ON THE QUESTION IT
COULD BE THAT- POTENTIALLY MOST
DISTRICTS WOULD SEEK MORE GRANT
MONEY AND SO THEY WOULD
EVENTUALLY HAVE TO THEY WOULD
EVENTUALLY HAVE TO EVERY
DISTRICT WOULD EVENTUALLY HAVE
TO ASK FOR MORE GRANT MONEY AND
EVENTUALLY THERE WOULDN'T BE
ENOUGH FOR MORE SCHOOLS TO
RECEIVE MONEY SO IT WOULD BE. A
LITTLE LESS DIFFERENT IT WOULD
BE MORE DIFFICULT TO GIVE
EVERYONE GRANT MONEY I'M NOT
SURE IF THIS ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION AS WELL BUT I'VE
NOTICED THROUGH ATTENDING THIS
CONFERENCE THAT A LOT OF
SCHOOLS ON. DO NOT. WE SHARE
THEY DON'T LIKE IT WHEN
SACRAMENTO IMPOSES A AMANDA A
OR LIKE A STATEWIDE REGULATION
ALL SCHOOLS THEY PREFER TO WORK
THINGS OUT A LOCAL LEVEL SO
WHENEVER I ASSUME THAT LIKE
WHENEVER SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS
PROPOSED WHERE IT'S A.
REQUIREMENT FOR SCHOOL
STATEWIDE I SURE I ASSUME IS
GONNA BE SOME BACKLASH TO THAT.
THAT'S BOTH AGREE POINTS IN
THAT- THAT IS ONE OF THINGS I
WORRY ABOUT IN THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD AS WE PASSED
DOWN NEW REQUIREMENTS MAKE NEW
REGULATIONS SHE WAS THE COST
BURDEN ON A LOCAL DISTRICTS AND
YOU POINTED OUT. THAT I NEVER
LIKE THIS MIGHT START EATING UP
MORE MONEY BUT I ALSO NOTICE
HERE PRESIDENT WHO WERE VERY
CAREFUL- TO CITED THIS IS.
ACTUALLY PRETTY EFFECTIVE USE
OF MONEY AND NOT GOING TO TAKE
A LOT OF MONEY SO I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THAT UP I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOU RECOGNIZING THAT
THE MORE BURDENS MANDATES WE DO
PUT ON LEVELS. THE MORE IT IT.
IT. IT EATS UP MONEY AND
THERE'S NOT MONEY FOR THAT NEXT
PROJECTS THAT WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL IT'S ALWAYS A BALANCE
UP HERE. IT'S ALWAYS A BOUNCE.
SO I THOUGHT- YOUR IDEAS WERE.
PRETTY WELL THOUGHT OUT- IN
FACT I HAVE THE CHIEF
FACILITIES EXPERT THE CAPITAL
WORKING IN MY OFFICE RIGHT NOW
LISTENING RIGHT NOW. WHO SAT ON
THIS COMMITTEE AS A AS A
CONSULTANT FOR MANY YEARS-
WHO'S PROBABLY TAKING NOTES SO
THAT'S GOOD. THAT'S GOOD-
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER SENATOR.
WELL I THINK THAT YOU- YOU
COVERED A LOT OF GROUND I THINK
YOU HIT THAT. HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD WHEN YOU SAID.
EFFECTIVE USE OF OUR FUNDING.
SO YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S A BIG
ARGUMENT APPEAR. ON AND ALSO
WILL STILL HAVE AN IMPACT. IN
SUPPORT OF A- CLEANER AND
ENVIRONMENT SO. I THINK YOU DID
DEEPER HOMEWORK THAN JUST WHAT
WAS PRESIDENT HERE. YOU DID
MUCH DEEPER THINKING SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU CAN CAN ONE AREA THAT COULD
BE ADDRESS UNDER THE YOU DIDN'T
BRING UP- BUT I THINK YOU
DIDN'T BRING IT UP FOR A REASON
AND THEY GIVE CITED IS THAT.
THE VERY EXPENSIVE I'LL I AS I
LOOK AT SCHOOLS I DRIVE AROUND
THE- THE TOWN I'LL LOOK AT
AREAS WHERE THERE'S GRASS.
WHERE THERE NEED NOT BE GRASS
WHEN I ME THAT LIKE BETWEEN
CLASSROOMS ARE KIDS DON'T PLAY-
IN WHAT IS THAT MEAN TO ME. THE
WAY I LOOK AT FACILITIES THAT
MEANS MAINTENANCE THAT'S A LOT
OF MAINTENANCE DOLLARS. WERE
SOME THAT GRASS IN MY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE COULD BE TAKEN UP
IN A- MAYBE SOME MORE- YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA FRIENDLY. VEGETATION
COULD BE PLANTED IN THERE
BECAUSE IT WOULD SAY WATER FOR
SURE. THE CUT DOWN ON
MAINTENANCE THOUGH I MEAN KNOWN
HAVE TO MOW IT EVERY WEEK AND
WOOD AND ONCE A MONTH SOMEONE
GOES THROUGH THEIR DOES SOME
BUT THAT'S ABOUT IT. AND I CAN
BE PRETTY COST EFFECTIVE IN THE
LONG RUN FOR SCHOOLS TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT EVEN ON THEIR OWN
THEY DON'T EVEN NEED AN
INCENTIVE TO. IN FACT. I THINK
ON THE RELEASE OF THEIR OWN
COST BURDENS FOR THAT'S ANOTHER
TOPIC WE WILL CONTINUE TODAY.
BUT I WON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. VERY WELL THE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE. TO BE TO
BE FAIR I DON'T ALLOW CLAPPING
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM BUT WE DO
TODAY SO. IT'S NOT A SPORTING
EVENT AS I WAS AND- ANYWAYS BUT
POLITICS IS KIND OF A SPORTS
SOMETIMES CORRECT SENATOR- WITH
THAT WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
SCHOOL OR SCHOOL SCHOOL SAFETY
TEAM. COME ON UP TO TAKE A SEAT
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AND YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL-
GOOD AFTERNOON ASKING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I THINK EVERY TIME
TODAY I'M JONATHAN HOLE FROM
THE ONE OF ALL UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
I'M IN THE FIFTY FIFTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AND THE TWENTY NINE
SENATE-DISTRICT. MY NAME IS
EMILY FROM FULLERTON JOINT
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS SIXTY
FIVE AND SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY
NINE. MY NAME IS BRADLEY RAMZI
FROM ANDERSON UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT ONE AND
SENATE-DISTRICT ONE I'M ALSO
SHOWS COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION STUDENT BOARD MEMBER.
RIGHT. OVER HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE SCHOOL SAFETY
PROCEDURES AND EMERGENCY
READINESS. OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DEFINITELY MADE GREAT LEAPS IN
ENSURING THAT SCHOOLS ARE
PREPARED FOR ADVERSE CONDITIONS
AND BY WAS INSTALLATIONS OF FOR
EXAMPLE THANKS TO AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN OF HOUSING TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. OUR EDUCATION CODE
SECTION THREE TWO TWO EIGHT TWO
NOW HOLD EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND LOCAL COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION RESPONSIBLE. FOR
DEVELOPING COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL
SAFETY PLANS. OF TODAY WOULD
LIKE TO PROPOSE IN ADDITION
ACTUALLY TO THAT SECTION
SECTION THREE TWO TWO EIGHT TWO
OF THIS. EDUCATION CODE- YES AT
THE SECTION ALSO REQUIRES
SCHOOLS TO CREATE A SAFETY
PROTOCOL TO ADDRESS THE
POSSIBILITY OF AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER. PULLING A FIRE ALARM
AS A WEAPON TO LOWER STUDENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM. I
LIKE TO BRING US BACK TO
VALENTINE'S DAY IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE DAY OF THE MARCH
YOUR HIGH SCHOOL SHOOTINGS IN
PARKLAND FLORIDA. THE SHOOTING
STARTED AN ALARM WENT OFF AND-
EVERYTHING WASIN DISARRAY
SHOULD WE EVACUATE OR SHOULD WE
HIGH END STAGE CHILDREN IN THE
CLASSROOM. WE LOST SEVENTEEN
LIVES THAT DAY WHEN THE SHOOTER
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THE CONFUSION
BETWEEN THE ORIGINAL EVACUATION
IN THE FINAL LOCKDOWN
CONSENSUS. STUDENTS RUN AROUND
IN CHAOS UNABLE TO DECIDE WHICH
SET OF INSTRUCTIONS FOLLOW
EVACUATE BECAUSE THE ALARM OR-
LOCK DOWN BECAUSE OF A SCHOOL
THREAT. THIS TRAGEDY SHOWS AN
INHERENT ISSUE IN OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND OUR REACTION-
PROCEDURES WITH FELL TO CONFIRM
ALERTS OR ALARMS BEFORE WE ACT.
THE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES OUR
EFFICIENCY AND AGGRAVATE THE
FEAR AND TENSION INHERENT IN
OUR EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEM.
HOW MANY STUDENTS DO YOU THINK
WOULD STILL BE ALIVE TODAY IF
WE DIDN'T MATTER IMMEDIATELY
EVACUATE. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE THREAT OF SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
DOES NOT AFFECT EVERY SIN IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER WAS SCHOOLS
BECOMING THE MOST COMMON
LOCATION WORK ACTIVE SHOOTINGS
OCCUR IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
UP THE PERSON MERGING SEE
PROTOCOLS WE HAVE IN PLACE. THE
PARKLAND SHOOTING HIGHLIGHTS
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS. A FIRE
ALARM LOWER THE STUDENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE SAFETY OF THEIR
CLASSROOM. THE PROBLEMS CLEAR
WE'RE NOT YEAH EQUIPPED TO
CONSIDER EVERY DANGER AND AS
WE'VE SEEN THIS INSUFFICIENCY
HAS TAKEN FAR TOO MANY LIVES.
WHEN APPROACHING THIS ISSUE WE
BEGAN TO REALIZE THAT SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA VERY
GREATLY FROM ACCESSIBILITY TO
ACCESSIBILITY TO EMERGENCY
RESOURCES TO ENVIRONMENTAL
LIMITATIONS. THEREFORE THIS IS
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTION. RATHER IT IS A
CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
HELD LOCALLY. ALL DISTRICTS
SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADDRESSING THESE CONCERNS WHAT
THE RISING FREQUENCY OF ACTIVE
SHOOTER THREATS WE NEED TO
REFORM THE SYSTEM NOW.
CURRENTLY IMMEDIATE ACTUATION
IS THE MOST COMMON RESPONSE TO
A FIRE ALARM HOWEVER THIS DOES
EVACUATION CAN BE USED AS A
TOOL BY ACTIVE SHOOTERS FULLER
STUDENTS OUT OF THE CLASSROOM.
THUS WE PROPOSE THAT UNDER
EDUCATION CODE THREE TWO TWO
EIGHT TWO. DISTRICTS ARE
REQUIRED TO CREATE A SAFETY
PROCEDURE PLAN IN THE INSTANCE
OF AN ACTIVE SHOOTER USING A
FIRE ALARM. WE LEAVE. WE LEAVE
THE SPECIFICS OF THESE
EMERGENCY PLANS UP TO THE
DISTRICTS LOT DEPENDING ON
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES. THEY CAN
TAILOR THE BEST SOLUTIONS
POSSIBLE. FOR INSTANCE A FIRE
PRONE AREA WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
POSTPONE EVACUATION WHEREAS IT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL FOR AN AREA
WITH MORE GUN VIOLENCE SUPPOSED
WHEN EVACUATION. TRAGEDY SUCH
AS THE PARK WHEN SHOOTING
COULD. COULD HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED SORRY. WE RESTART
TRAGEDY SUCH AS THE PARK ON
SHOOTING COULD HAVE BEEN
MITIGATED OR PREVENTED WITH NEW
POLICIES FOR EMERGENCY
PROTOCOLS. THE SAFETY PROTOCOLS
THAT ARE PROPOSAL REQUIRES OF
DISTRICTS ARE CURRENTLY IN
PRACTICE BY SEVERAL SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
COLORADO. WHENEVER FILL SABLE
DELEGATES FROM SHOTS UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT ONE SENATE-DISTRICT
ONE IS AN EXAMPLE OF WATER
PROPOSAL WHICH IS TO ACCOMPLISH.
ACCORDING TO THEIR NEW
PROCEDURES THE DISTRICT NOW
GOES INTO A LOCKDOWN WHEN AN
EMERGENCY ALARM IS ACTIVATED.
THIS PROTECTS THE STUDENTS IN
THE SPECIFIC CASE OF AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER PULLING THE FIRE ALARM.
THIS LOCKDOWN PROCEDURE IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE AS TO HOW
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW SAFETY
PROCEDURES MAKES THE SCHOOLS
SAFER FOR OUR MODERN
EMERGENCIES. THIS FURTHER
PROVES A NECESSITY FOR OUR
PROPOSAL TO BE APPROVED IN
ORDER TO REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO
IMPLEMENT SAFER MERGING SEE
STRATEGIES. THIS PROTOCOL IS A
WONDERFUL EXAMPLE OF WHAT OUR
PROPOSAL WISHES TO ACCOMPLISH
BUT AGAIN IS IN NO WAY THE SUB
STANDARD. NO ONE. CAN PUT A
PRICE ON THE VALUE OF LIFE.
THIS IS NOT A MATTER OF
STATISTICS FOR POLITICS IT IS
OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE THAT WE
PROTECT OUR STUDENTS THEY ARE
THE FUTURE AND THEIR SAFETY NOT
ONLY DETERMINES THE WELL BEING
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
ALSO THE WELFARE OF FUTURE
GENERATIONS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND WE HOPE YOU
CONSIDER A PROVISION TO ENACT A
SAFER SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT WE NOW
OPEN THE FLOOR TO ANY COMMENTS
CONCERNS OR QUESTIOS. GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO I DIDN'T
LEAVE ME UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR ASK FOR
AN ESTABLISHED PROTOCOL IN A
SCHOOL WHERE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT HAPPEN ARE YOU ASKING
FORCE. A TYPE OF BELL THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAN A FIRE BELL WITH
THAT SO WE'RE ASKING FOR
DISTRICTS TO CREATE A PROTOCOL-
IN THE SITUATION OF A ACTIVE
SHOOTER HOLDING THE FIRE ALARM
WHICH LOWERS STUDENTS OUT A
CLASSROOM WHICH IS A HUGE
SAFETY CONCERNS OKAY. I
UNDERSTAND THAT HAVING READ
AND- MANY A LOCK ON MYSELF OKAY
SOME RIGHT BY WAS A MONTH FOR
FIVE HOURS ONCE AND IT IT BY
TALIBAN A LOCKDOWN VERY
INTERESTING AND. SCARY
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR HELLO THERE'S OUTSIDE YOUR-
AND YOU'RE GONNA HEAR SIRENS.
NO IS YOU NEED TO TURN OFF THE
LIGHTS LOCKED THE DOOR DROPPED
THE- CAN'T CONTROL ANYTHING IS
GOING ON OUTSIDE THAT ROOM BUT
YOU HEAR IT GOING ON. SO IT'S A
VERY IT'S A VERY SCARY
EXPERIENCE FOR YOURSELF BUT
ALSO YOU'VE GOT YOU KNOW THIRTY
FIVE PLUS SOMETIMES STUDENTS TO
PROTECT AND RECOGNIZE- SO- I. I
CAN APPRECIATE A LOCKDOWN FOR
SURE I JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT
HAVING BEEN THROUGH MANY MYSELF.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT PROTOCOL
MIGHT LOOK LIKE I AM A SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL FOR. WHAT WHAT WHAT
OR AT SCHOOL BOARD WHAT KIND OF
POLICY WHAT I DEVELOP WHAT
WOULD IT LOOK LIKE. AT MY
SCHOOL SITE. ON WHAT I DO SO
THE EXAMPLE THAT WE HAVE IS
THREE SHOTS UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE WAY IN WHICH STATE
RUN THEIR PROTOCOL IS WHEN THE
FIRE ALARM SOUNDS- TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS HAD IN THE CLASSROOMS
TEACHERS. AS THEY ARE LOCKING
THE DOOR LOOK OUTSIDE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE NEW
STUDENTS OUTSIDE THEY ALSO DO.
AND SMELL WITH A VISUAL
TRANSCEIVER CAN SEE FIRE OR IF
THEY CAN SMELL SMOKE IN THAT
CASE IF THERE IS THEY THEN
CONTACT ADMINISTRATION WHO THAT
PUTS US AT LEAST TWO TIRES. AND
LET THEM KNOW THAT AND YOU HAVE
EVERY BACK AT THAT POINT.
OTHERWISE IF THEY SMELL NO
SMOKE SEE NO FIRE THEY ARE IN A
LOCK DOWN PROCEDURE INTEL
OTHERWISE NOTIFIED BY THE
SCHOOL. THAT IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE- THAT IS NOT OUR DIRECT
PROTOCOL BECAUSE OF COURSE YOU
WANT TO LEAVE THIS UP TO THE
DISTRICT THEMSELVES TO THE
SIDE. LIKE YOUR LOCAL CONTROL
ASPECT FOR SURE BECAUSE OUR
DISTRICTS ARE DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DIFFERENT IN A SAM IN THE HIGH
SCHOOL IN OTHER STUDENTS FROM
THAT WELL AS A HUGE PLACE THAT
IS A REAL BIG PLACE IN THAT
BRITAIN DIFFERENT DYNAMIC. I
JUST SEEMS. COUNTER IN THE FAR
ALARM GOES OFF RUN INTO MY
CLASS. THIS WONDERING GOD. I'M
SO THAT IS WORD SAYING. SO WALL
OF FIRE ALARM TYPICALLY GOES
OFF WERE USED TO RUNNING AWAY.
THAT'S KIND OF THE POINT OF WE
WANT SCHOOLS TO DEVELOP A
SYSTEM- FOR WHEN THE FIRE
ALARMS PULLED AS IF AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER WERE TO PULL IT. UP
BECAUSE YOU WANT THEM TO ASSUME
AN ACTIVE SHOOTER HAS PULLED
ATTRACTIVE. YES OR ELSE- YOU
JUST BE RUNNING OUT OF DANGER
AND NOT KNOWING IT. SO THIS IS
LETTING THEM FIGURE OUT OKAY
DID AN ACTIVE SHOOTER JUST PULL
THIS ALARM. DO WE RUN OUTSIDE
BECAUSE IT IS A FIRE OR DID AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER PULLS ALARM SO
WE'RE GOING TO WALK DOWN.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY SHASTA
HIGH SCHOOL HAS A PROCEDURE TO
IMMEDIATELY GOING TO LOCK DOWN.
AND THEN INTO EVACUATION. AND
TO BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF
SCHOOLS WOULD FOLLOW THAT TYPE
OF. BALL BUT OF COURSE SB PRINT
EACH. OF COURSE HE SEES THIS.
THEY SAID YOU CLASS TO. FIRE
YOU KNOW ONE GOING BACK IN. YOU
ARE THE MANY OTHERS YOU I'M.
OKAY I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO
THINK THIS YEAR BECAUSE I GET I
GET I GET YOUR POINT THAT
SOMEONE COULD PULL THE FIRE
ALARM STUDENTS HEAD OUT TO THE
FIELD WITH A TYPICALLY LINE UP
AND WAVE THE TEACHER COME OUT
CALL ROLE. RIGHT THAT'S WHAT
THEY DO. YEAH AND HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU. HOW DO YOU RESPOND
TO THAT DYNAMIC I. THINK THIS
IS AN INTERESTING. POINT THAT I
DON'T REALLY I. THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT QUITE FRANKLY WHAT I'M
USED TO HAPPENING. QUITE
FRANKLY IS IN IN AS IN A LOCK
DOWN SOMEONE GETTING ON THE PA.
SAYING LOCKDOWN. LOCKDOWN SAY
FIVE TIMES. THAT WAIT FIVE
SECONDS AND SAY IT AGAIN. SO
EVERYBODY AND EVERYBODY HEARS
AND AROUND THE SCHOOL THEY NEED
TO REPEAT MULTIPLE TO GET TO
SAY ONCE. RIGHT NEEDS TO BE
SAID. AND YOU WILL COME ON
TEMAS I CONTINUE THE LOCKDOWN.
YEAH RIGHT SO. ON WHAT WE'RE
KIND OF AIMING FOR IS THAT. THE
SCHOOLDISTRICTS CAN DECIDE.
HOW THEY WANT TO IMPLEMENTED.
SO IF THEY WANTED TO IMPLEMENT.
THAT IT. IS AN IMMEDIATE
EVACUATION. IT COULD BE AN
IMMEDIATE EVACUATION. OR IT
COULD BE. IMMEDIATE LOCKDOWN
OR- WHATEVER. HAPPY MEDIUM.
SIZED BASICALLY WHAT YOU WANT
TO SCHOOL DISTRICT TO DO. A
SCHOOL BOARD. IS AND THIS WE DO
THIS A LOT OF HERE WE SEE WE
DIRECTOR SCHOOL. WE DIRECT-
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD. RIGHT AND
THERE'S A WHAT A THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TEN THOUSAND
SCHOOLS A LOT OF THEM. AND
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT. IN
GEOGRAPHY. AT SOME. DIFFERENT
PLACES. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO
DO IT THIS WAY WE HAVE SAY YOU.
ADOPT A POLICY. THAT WORKS. FOR
YOU. EVEN SCHOOLS ARE.
DEFINITELY SOME THE STUDENTS
ARE ALL PRETTY MUCH INSIDE SOME.
THEY'RE ALL OUTSIDE. SO SOME
YOU HAVE TO CROSS STREET. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR APPROACH. IN
THAT YOU'RE RECOGNIZING THAT WE
ARE. A DIVERSE STATE. IN
GEOGRAPHY AND THAT WE SHOULD
HANSEL LOCALS. TO DEVELOP THEIR
POLICY BUT THAT THEY SHOULD DO
BALLOT SUCH A POLICY SO THAT
SENATOR. IS WHERE YOU CAN ADD
SOMETHING- I WAS JUST GOING TO
LIKE TO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WERE NOT OUR OUR
OUR POINT HERE IS TO EMPHASIZE
IN THAT SECTION OF THE
EDUCATION CODE SECTION TO DO A
TO. THAT SECTION EMPHASIZES THE
WHAT STUDENTS HAVE TO BE
PREPARED FOR LIKE FIRES OR YOU
CAN WORK- EARTHQUAKES WE'RE NOT
SAYING WHAT YOU NEED TO DO WE
JUST NEED THEM TO BE AWARE OF
THE ABILITY OF THIS AND THAT.
AND BE PREPARED NOT EARLY. SAY
A LOT AS NECESSARY. SO I HAVE A
QUESTION THANK YOU. SOME IN
MAKING THAT MAKING THE CASE FOR
THIS. ISSUE TO BE INCLUDED
WHICH I THINK IS VERY. VERY
GOOD OF YOU TO BRING THAT TO
OUR ATTENTION- YOU MENTIONED-
AGAIN JUST IN MAKING THE CASE
THAT THEY WERE- IN THE FIRST
FORTY SIX WEEKS OF TWENTY
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE SHOOTINGS.
AND AT LEAST ONE SCHOOL
SHOOTING PER PER WEEK- BUT YOU
ONLY MENTIONED- PARKLAND AS AN
INCIDENT OF. YOU SAY ON IT THIS
INCIDENT DEMONSTRATES THAT FIRE
ALARM IS A COMMON WAY. FOR
ACTIVE SHOOTERS TO TARGET
STUDENTS. OF IS THAT REALLY
WHAT YOUR INFORMATION FOUND I
OR YOU DIDN'T IT IS SORT OF
MATCH UP. THAT PART WITH THE
FIRST SET OF FACTS OR
INFORMATION SO WHAT WE KIND OF
FOUND WAS THAT PARKLAND
SHOOTING WAS REALLY A- IT'S
BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED COMPARED
TO MANY OTHERS HAVE JUST BEEN
SAID THERE WAS A SCHOOL
SHOOTING THERE WAS THIS MANY
VICTIMS THEY DON'T REALLY GO
INTO THE FACT OF. HOW IT WENT
DOWN OR- WHETHER NOT THE FIRE
ALARM WAS PULLED SO IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO GET THOSE
STATISTICS AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
A FARMS BEEN TOLD. IN THE
FUTURE WE HAVE FOUND THERE IS A
SLIGHT MENTIONS OF FIRE ALARMS
BEING PULLED BUT WE DO SEE THAT
AS A LARGE RISK- WHETHER OR NOT
IT IS BEEN SHOWN IS COMMON IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT SEEMS AS
IT'S BECOMING A COMMON THING
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES FROM
THE STE- DIFFERENT STUDIES THAT
WE FOUND. ALSO BEING LIKE SUCH
A HIGH PROFILE CASE WE FELT
THAT LIKE YOU GUYS WOULD
ALREADY HAVE SOME BACKGROUND IN
IT RESONATE MORE. AND ALSO THAT
LAKE LINK IT TOOK ALL THE
WALKOUTS AND HOW LIKE STUDENTS
WANT CHANGE NOW. AND REGARDLESS
OF THE FREQUENCY OF ACTUALLY
USING A FIRE ALARM TO YOUR
STUDENTS OUT- IT'S STILL
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S- AN
EASILY ADJUSTABLE. AND IT'S NOT
AS IN WILL NOT NECESSARILY
AFFECT EVERYONE BUT IT'S- EASY
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WELL I THINK WE COULD EMPHASIZE
THAT POINT A LOT MORE BECAUSE I
THINK YEAR YOU'RE RIGHT ON THAT
RIGHT ON ON ON THAT AND- YOU
DON'T NEED TO MAKE THE CASE
THAT. IT'S COMMON IT'S A COMMON
USE NEED TO MAKE THE CASE THAT
IT IS USED AND THEREFORE IT
SHOULD BE AN ELEMENT IN THE
SAFETY PLAN. JUST FOR YOUR
FUTURE. THANK YOU SENATOR I
WILL THANK YOU VERY WELL
PRESENTED AND VERY WELL DONE
AND GOOD RESPONSES TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT WITH RONNIE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM OUR MENTAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH PANEL.
YEAH
. YOU MAY INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES AND PROCEED WHEN
READY. OKAY THANK GREETINGS
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION. MY. THE JUNIOR
OLYMPIANS HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
SUIT PARTY UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT I AM PART OF THE
SEVENTY NINE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND THE FORTY S. SENATE
DISTRICT. SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THE THIRTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AND THE FIFTH SENATE
DISTRICT. MY NAME IS SHERRY A
WHOLE CARTY I'M A JUNIOR AT
GRANITE BAY HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
ROSE BOWL JOINT UNIFIED HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND I'M PART
OF THE SIX ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND THE FIRST SENATE DISTRICT.
WE ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS OR CAST TO
DISCUSS THE ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELLNESS WITHIN
PRIMARY AND SECONDARY EDUCATION.
IT IS UNDENIABLE THAT WELLNESS
DEFINED AS THE MINDSET
ACTIVITIES AND HABITS WE
PRACTICE TO COMBAT STRESS
DEPRESSION AND OTHER NEGATIVE
MIND STATES IS NOT PRIORITIZE
IN THE CURRENT EDUCATION
SYSTEM. HOWEVERSOME SCHOOLS
HAVE TAKEN INITIATIVE. CASES
SUCH AS THE SACRAMENTO BASED
LEONARDO DA VINCI PRE K.
THROUGH EIGHTH GRADE SCHOOL AND
WHICH FOURTH GRADERS SPEND ONE
DAY A WEEK SINGING ALONG TO
SONGS WELL I EXERCISING TO
PROMOTE WELL BEING. AND CREATE
A HIGH SCHOOL IN WHICH TEACHERS
USE POSITIVE CREATIVE
AFFIRMATIONS PRIOR TO TAX A
TACTIC WHICH HAS REPORTEDLY TO
INCREASE TEST SCORES OVERTIME
AND STUDENTS TAKING REQUIRED
ART CLASSES. ALLEVIATE STRESS
BOTH SHOW THAT WELLNESS
TECHNIQUES HAVE WORKED
PROMOTING LONG TERM BENEFITS ON
MENTAL HEALTH. DO THESE VARIOUS
EXERCISES STUDENTS EXPRESSED
FEELINGS OF GRATITUDE AND
RELIEF HAVING BEEN GIVEN
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES OUTSIDE
OF THE TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM
ENVIRONMENT A PLACE IN WHICH
STUDENTS ARE USUALLY GEARED
TOWARDS STEM CURRICULUM.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR BIOTECHNOLOGY
INFORMATION ART STIMULATES THE
RELEASE OF DOPAMINE ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO FEEL HAPPIER AND
GIVING THOSE STRUGGLING WITH
ANXIETY OR DEPRESSION A
REPRIEVE. HOWEVER IT IS
UNDISPUTED BOWLTHAT THE LACK
OF THESE EXERCISES OR ANY
SIGNIFICANT MEASURE OF
NONTRADITIONAL LEARNING WHETHER
THAT BE EMOTIONAL OR PHYSICAL
CAUSES HARM WITH CALIFORNIA'S
MENTAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES ACT
STATING THAT CHILDREN LEFT
UNTREATED OFTEN BECOME UNABLE
TO LEARN OR PARTICIPATE IN A
NORMAL SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT. WELL
ASSEMBLY ALL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN A NEWLY ESTABLISHED BILL
APPROVED LAST YEAR EXPLORED
SIMILAR CONTACTS WITH OUR
PROPOSAL THE TO APPROACH MENTAL
HEALTH IN FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT WAYS. AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN REQUIRED LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO CREATE
SUICIDE PREVENTION INTERVENTION
AND POST TENSIONED PLANS FOR
STUDENTS H. K. THROUGH TWELVE.
WHILE THE STEP IS ADMIRABLE
WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING FOCUSES
ON A DIFFERENT ASPECT OF MENTAL
HEALTH FOCUSING MORE ON
WELLNESS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
YOUNG STUDENTS WITH NECESSARY
MINDFULNESS SELF CARE EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE AND RELEVANT
STRESS DIMINISHING PRACTICES
THAT ARE INFLUENTIAL TO THEIR
LONG TERM GROWTH. WE PROPOSE
THAT IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH A
COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL WELL BEING
EDUCATION ALL LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES SHALL COLLABORATE WITH
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SCHOOL COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE LOCAL
COULD COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN. TO CREATE A MORE SCHOOL
EMOTIONAL WELLNESS PLANS FOR
EACH ACADEMIC GRADE
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE. EACH GRADE LEVEL WILL
LEARN NEW SKILLS THAT BUILD
UPON THEIR SKILLS FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS. AT THAT ARE APPLICABLE
TO THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
THIS PLAN WILL TOUCH ON WHAT
MENTAL HEALTH IS AND HOW
STUDENTS CAN MAINTAIN A HEALTHY
MENTAL WELL BEING BY
INCORPORATING HEALTHY PRACTICES
INTO THEIR EVERYDAY LIFE STYLES.
THIS WILL HELP TO PREVENT
ANXIETY LOWER GENERAL STRESS
LEVELS AND PRACTICE OUT OF
REACH FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. RATHER THAN CREATE NEW
CURRICULUM TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS WILL INCORPORATE
THESE MENTAL WELLNESS
TECHNIQUES AND PRACTICES INTO
DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES OUR
APPROACH TO MENTAL HEALTH IS A
POSITIVE ONE LOOKING AT
TECHNIQUES LIKE MEDITATION YOGA
AND MINE FOR MINUTES THAT CAN
GREATLY BENEFIT ONE'S MENTAL
HEALTH. IS THIS YOUR VALLEY
MIDDLE SCHOOL IMPLEMENTED A
MENTAL HEALTH WHAT THIS PLAN IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THROUGH
MEDITATION PROGRAM THAT
GARNERED IMPRESSIVE RESULTS
DRASTICALLY REDUCING ITS
EXPANSION RATES DURING A TIME
OF HIGH CRIME AND VIOLENCE
RATES FOR THE AREA. THE SCHOOL
ALSO SAW IMPROVED DISAPPEARED
WITH DAILY ATTENDANCE RATES AND
GRADE POINT AVERAGES AND WAS
REPORTED TO EVEN HAVE SOME OF
THE HELP YOU STUDENTS IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO AREA. IT IS CLEAR
FROM BASED ON THAT WELL THIS
ACTIVITIES IN SCHOOLS NOT ONLY
A STUDENTS WILL BE FOR THE-
QUALITY OF SCHOOL CULTURE THERE
IS OF COURSE A COST TO THESE
ACTIONS IN RELATION TO THE
OVERALL PRICE PASTA SO SEATED
THE CREATION OF AN EMOTIONAL
WELLNESS PLAN WILL COST MONEY
TO. USE RELATING TO THE TIME
REQUIRED EL IS TO PLAN. HELLO
THE LAST STOP OF THIS. MOTION
WILL BE IT'S NOT BEEN FULLY
DRESSED. THE COST WILL ULTIMATE
AND INVESTMENT THROUGH THE
EMOTIONAL BEING YOUNG IN FULL
BY THE OCEAN A WITNESS BUT- ARE
NOT ONLY CONCERN IMMEDIATE AND
SAID WE TAKE CONSIDERATION THE
LONG TERM THE PREVENTION.
CURRENTLY IN PLACE ARE
BENEFICIAL HOWEVER WE BELIEVE.
CAN BE. HE TOOK THE COAT I CAN
GO OVER THEM WITH THE ABILITY
TO SOLVE ANY PROBLEMS THEY ARE
FACED WITH A YOUNG AGE WHEN
THEY'RE NEUROPLASTICITY IS AT
ITS HIGHEST IT IS EMOTIONAL
WELLNESS PLANS ARE PROPERLY
IMPLEMENTED STUDENTS WILL BE
ABLE TO ALSO REALLY GRADUATE
WITH THE MENTAL TOOLS GIVEN TO
MAINTAIN THEIR OWN MENTAL
HEALTH AND BECOME PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY. THANK YOU
WE ARE NOT I WOULDN'T OPEN TO
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN VERY. VERY
WELL PRESENTED AND VERY
ARTICULATE- SO LET ME JUST. BE
CLEAR SO I UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT
WOULD YOU WANT. WHAT YOUR BILL
SEEKS TO DO IT SEEKS TO HAVE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS DEVELOP
A MENTAL WELLNESS PLAN. THAT
WOULD THEN BE IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS THE DISTRICT AND ALL
SCHOOLS IN GRADES K. THROUGH
TWELVE. HEY AND THAT PLAN COULD
MEAN MANY THINGS AGAIN ARE YOU
TAKING ON THAT LOCAL CONTROL-
MONTEREY APPRECIATE THAT
SOMEONE WAS I GOT YOU. AND
THEN- KNOWING ME BUT EITHER WAY.
TELL TELL ME WHAT THIS MIGHT
LOOK LIKE AGAIN ON THE GROUND
AND I'M OUT OF SCHOOL THE
PLANTS BEEN DEVELOPED IT'S BEEN
ADOPTED BY THE LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD. WHAT MIGHT THIS MEAN.
WHAT MIGHT I SEE. SO THIS CAN
ENTERED INTRODUCED A COUPLE OF
TECHNIQUES- INCLUDING LIKE
MINDFUL MINUTES- MEDITATION
PRACTICES. ANYTHING TO LIKE.
INTRODUCE STUDENTS TO. LIKE
WAYS TO COPE WITH. STRESS AND
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION. IN
ORDER TO- DEVELOP THOSE IDEAS
FURTHER IN THEIR EDUCATION.
LIKE THE EXAMPLES WE GAVE ACT
HI THEY CAN BE SMALL THINGS
LIKE A CREDO TEACHER HAD THEM.
JUST A SAKE- POSITIVE
AFFIRMATIONS PRIOR TO A TEST I
THINK IT WAS I KNOW MORE THAN I
THINK I DO. SO THAT WAY THEY'RE
CONFIDENT GOING INTO THE TEST.
FOR PERFORM BETTER. BUT IS ALSO
SPEAKS THE OVERALL MENTAL HOW
THE STUDENTS BY. CHANGING THE
DAY UP A BIT. IN DOING I HEARD
EXERCISE EARLIER. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHAT WE MIGHT DO
YOGA. AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE MICHAEL DOT CUTTING RIGHT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. WHATEVER
FITS OUR- OUR GEOGRAPHY
HEARING- OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU I GET IT I GET IT AT A
WHICH REALLY SEEKING DISTRICTS
TO JUST BE MINDFUL. OF THEIR
NEED TO ADDRESS STUDENTS HELP
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
THANK YOU. THAT. SENATOR AND I
SHOULD. NOTE THE PRESENCE OF A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OFSHE KALRA
RIGHT THERE HE'S FROM THE SAN
JOSE AREA'S VERY NICE GUY. THE
NICEST GUYS THE STATE ASSEMBLY
CARES ABOUT PEOPLE VERY KIND
AND LOVES A LOT A LAWS I TELL
YOU THAT SENATOR GOING. OKAY
VERY GOOD- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL OF THE WE WORK THAT
WENT INTO THIS. DID YOU THINK
ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD. EITHER
RESOURCES OR IDEAS ABOUT. WHERE
WHERE THE IDEAS WOULD COME FROM
OF WHAT IT INVOLVES TEACHERS
GETTING TRAINED TO DO THIS
OBVIOUSLY TEACHERS WOULD YOU
KNOW NOT ALL TEACHERS HAVE THE
SAME IDEAS OR COULD EVEN COME
UP WITH THE- IDEAS SO. HOW DO
YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT EITHER IN
COST. OR THE PROCESS OF COMING
UP WITH THE WELLNESS PROGRAM
THE ROLE OF TEACHERS AND THE
KIND OF TRAINING OR PREPARATION
THAT THEY WOULD NEED. TO CARRY
OUT A WELLNESS PROGRAM IN THE
BEST WAY POSSIBLE. SO WE DO YOU
REALIZE THAT THIS WOULD BE AN
INVESTMENT BUT WE THINK WOULD
BE VERY BENEFICIAL INVESTMENT
SINCE IT'S PRIORITIZE IS
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH AND
THEIR WELL BEING- WE REALIZE
THAT IT WOULD A PLAN WE NEED TO
BE. GIVEN BY THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES I CREATED BY
THEM AND THEN THERE FOR
PRESENTED TO THE TEACHERS AND
TO GIVE NEXT MISSION TO THE
TEACHERS. SO IT WOULD BE IN THE
PROCESS OF CREATING A PLAN THAT
IS FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO BE
ADOPTED DIFFERENT WAYS AND
DISTRICTS. BUT ALSO GIVES KIND
OF LIKE A STANDARD OF HOW
TEACHERS SHOULD APPROACH THEIR
STUDENTS WELL BEING MENTAL WELL
BEING. YEAH. A LITTLE ADDING ON
TO THAT KIND OF GOING BACK TO
WHAT NO ANA SAID DISTRICTS
WOULD COME UP WITH THOSE PLANS
AND GIVE THEM TO THE SCHOOLS
AND TEACHERS SUCH AS EXAMPLES
OF WHAT THEY COULD DO SUCH AS
YOGA ARE MINDFUL MINUTES AND
TEACHERS COULD DECIDE WHICH
ONES THEY WANTED TO DO AND
IMPLEMENT THOSE IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS. I APPRECIATE THE
FLEXIBILITY. BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK YOU'D FIND A GUY LIKE ME
CAN OF BREAKING INTO YOGA. IN
ANOTHER CLASS WHAT OR WHAT YES
YES EXACTLY. I WOULD THAT I
MISSED KALRA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I DON'T KNOW YOU MIGHT
LIKE YOU THINK YOU SEE IT WOULD
FIT FOR HIM WELL NO I SAY GO DO
IT THE PERSONAL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU I WAS TRYING
OTHER COMMITTEE AND I HAVE A
MOTHER MEETING COMING UP A
LITTLE BUT I DON'T WANT TO MISS
OUT ON COMING TO AS MUCH AS I
CAN OF THIS MOODY'S
PRESENTATIONS. AT ALL. WE HAVE
A DIFFERENT PROBLEM I THINK
LEGISLATIVE. THINK THEY KNOW
MORE THAN THEY ACTUALLY DO IS-
WE DON'T. HAVE TO DO THAT
MANTRA- HERE IN SACRAMENTO BUT-
I WOULD SAY I REALLY APPRECIATE
PRESENTATION BECAUSE- IN. THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT I WENT TO THE
SIDE UNION. DASHER IMPLEMENTED
A START WITH ONE SCHOOL IN THIS
ARTIC SPENDING IT- MINDFULNESS.
YOGA ALTERNATE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION SO THERE'S CONFLICTS
RATHER THAN JUST A SPENDING ONE
STUDENTS SPANISH IT. THEY HAVE
TO GET THEM. TO THINK NOTED TO
SOME OF THESE PRACTICES AND
THEN. TRY TO RESOLVE AFTER
DOING SOME OF THESE COMPONENTS
PRACTICES WHETHER OR NOT
CALMER. STATE OF MIND. AND WHAT
THE DISTRICTS BOUND AS THAT THE
ACATHE- AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE IS GOT UP. AND
ACTUALLY PAY MORE THAN PAID FOR
ITSELF. BY JUST. HAVING
STUDENTS ATTENDING SCHOOL UP.
AND SO IS DEFINITELY. A WIN
WIN. THE UP FRONT COST AS YOU
NOTED WOULD BE THE ISSUES LIKE
MAKING SURE THE DISTRICTS OF
THE MINISTER OF COSTS THAT UP
PROGRAM. BUT I THINK IN THE
LONG RUN. AS STATED IT WOULD
DEFINITELY SAVE DISTRICTS
MONEY. AND WILL HAVE THE
ULTIMATE GOAL WHICH HAVE MORE
STUDENTS IN. PREPARED IN CLASS
PREPARED AND HAVING THE RIGHT
MINDSET TO SUCCEED SO. EVEN THE
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU. TING
OF COMMON. SENSE HI. YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION VERY WELL
DONE YOU SHOULD BE PROUD OF
YOURSELF. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
PANEL WILL BE. A MINORITY
STUDENT SUPPORT MINORITY
STUDENTS SUPPORT THEY COULD
COME FOR PLEASE
. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS TEAM MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ELLA PASCO
AND I'M A SENIOR TENDING SAMMY
NEED A HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
THIRTY THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND A TOUGH SENATE-DISTRICT MY
NAME IS A FOOT TALL AND I AM A
JUNIOR ATTENDING MONTA VISTA
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE SIXTEENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND THE
SEVENTH. SENATE DISTRICT MY
NAME IS MICHELLE ALICE AND I AM
A JUNIOR ATTENDING NORTHGATE
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE FOURTEENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND THE SEVEN
SENATE DISTRICT ON BEHALF
DISABLED DELEGATION WE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY DIRECT THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING. TO
LIMIT A CULTURAL COMMON
REQUIREMENT FOR PRELIMINARY
MULTI AND SINGLE SUBJECT
TEACHING CREDENTIALS. UPON
ENTERING MY AP WORLD HISTORY
CLASS I KNEW I HAD TWO THINGS
TO LOOK FORWARD TO. ARABLE HAND
CRAMPS FROM WEEKLY CHAPTER
NOTES. AND MRS PAROO SO A
TEACHER PRES BY STUDENTS AND
FACULTY ALIKE. HOWEVER WHAT MRS
PROOF SO ISN'T OFTEN PRIEST FOR
IS TO RESPECT OF DIFFERENT
CULTURES. AS A MUSLIM MALE
GROWING UP IN SUCH A POLITICAL
AND POLITICAL CLIMATE IT
BROUGHT ME SALAS SEEING A
TEACHER TO TRY TO BREAK THROUGH
THE MANY FALSE NOTION
SURROUNDING MY FAITH. WHETHER
IT BE THROUGH HER PARTICIPATION
IN THE WORLD HER JOB DAY OR
PROVIDING A SAFE SPACE IN HER
CLASSROOM FOR THE SCHOOL'S
MUSLIM STUDENT ASSOCIATION
EVERY FRIDAY. MRS PROOF SO HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT REGARDLESS OF
RACE GENDER RELIGION OR
ETHNICITY. TEACHERS CAN SERVE
AS A POWERFUL FORCE IN BRIDGING
ETHNIC DIVIDES WHEN CULTURALLY
COMPETENT. DESPITE BEING A
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM FOR ELEVEN YEARS IT WAS
NOT UNTIL MY JUNIOR YEAR THAT I
WAS FINALLY TAUGHT BY A TEACHER
TO ACTIVELY SOUGHT CULTURAL
COMPETENCY. DEFINED AS A SET OF
BEHAVIORS ATTITUDES AND BELIEFS
THAT ALLOW PROFESSIONAL TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN A VARIETY OF CROSS
CULTURAL ENVIRONMENTS. MY A. P.
LITERATURE TEACHER MISS REED IS
NOT A PERSON OF COLOR BUT
REGULARLY ATTENDS ANTI RACISM
SEMINARS AND LECTURES TO
IMPLEMENT THESE PRACTICES IN
THE CLASSROOM AND TEACHER
STUDENTS TO BE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. AS A PERSON OF COLOR
HAVING A TEACHER OPENLY TALK
ABOUT CULTURAL DIFFERENCES WAS
AN UNPRECEDENTED EXPERIENCE AND
I GREATLY APPRECIATED THE
FOSTER I'M NOT ONLY MY PEERS
CULTURAL KNOWLEDGE OF MY OWN.
HOWEVER EVERY SCHOOL WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE A
MYSTERY OR MRS BRUCE SO. THIS
CULTURAL COMPETENCY REQUIREMENT
IS IMPORTANT FOR ACCREDITING
THAT OUT NEWS FOR ALL TYPES THE
TEAM IS IN CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR.
WHILE OBSERVING CULTURAL
COMPETENCY ACROSS VARIOUS
REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA WE
DISCOVERED A PLETHORA OF
CONCERNING CASES. MOST NOTABLY
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. A
STUDENT FROM MY SCHOOL DISTRICT
RAN FOR A SB PRESIDENT UNDER
THE PLATFORM AND I QUOTE. ELECT
TO ME AND I WILL PROTECT YOU
FROM ISIS. INITIALLY THE
STUDENT WAS DISQUALIFIED BY THE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATION AFTER HIS
CAMPAIGN VIDEO WAS SHOWN TO THE
SCHOOL. HOWEVER FOLLOWING LEGAL
ACTION HE ATTEMPTED THE SCHOOL
BACKTRACKED AND GRANTED THE
STUDENT THE PRESIDENCY. IN
LIGHT OF THE SITUATION BELIEVE
THAT YOU INFORMED EDUCATOR
PERSPECTIVES ON THE EPERIENCES
OF MARGINALIZED STUDENTS.
ALLOWS FOR THE PROLIFERATION OF
HATE SPEECH ACADEMIC INEQUALITY
AND INJUSTICE IN THE CLASSROOM.
HI TEACHERS IN THE SCHOOL BEEN
TRAINED IN CULTURAL COMPETENCY
AND HOW TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPACT. ON THE SCHOOL'S MUSLIM
STUDENTS. SUCH A CAMP WOULD
MOST LIKELY HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED. AB THREE THREE ONE
TWO THREE TWENTY ETHNIC STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM ADOPTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION WILL PROMOTE
COLLECTIVE RACIAL EMPOWERMENT.
BANKER JEAN COAT CULTURAL
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW DIFFERENT
GROUPS HAVE STRUGGLED AND
WORKED TOGETHER. THE PROPOSED
CULTURAL COMPETENCY TREE
TEACHER TRAINING WOULD BE ADDED
THREE PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS OF
THE DC. DEVELOPING WHICH. AND
INSTRUCTION AND HEALTH
EDUCATION. CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TRAINING SHOULD BE STANDARD
ACROSS ALL MULTI AND SINGLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE THE EDUCATORS WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FACILITATE
HEALTHY CONVERSATIONS
SURROUNDING A VARIETY OF
CULTURAL IDENTITIES AS WELL AS
PREVENT CONFLICT. THIS
CONDITION FOR ACCREDITATION
PROGRAMS WILL BE A DOCTORAL
BASED ON EACH SCHOOL'S SPECIFIC
DEMOGRAPHIC WILL INCLUDE THE
BASELINE KNOWLEDGE A PROFICIENT
UNDERSTANDING OF OTHER CULTURES
AND WILL TEACH EDUCATORS TO
INTERACT WITH CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY DIFFERENT
INDIVIDUALS. AND POINT
TECHNIQUES SUCH AS ACTIVE
LISTENING ELABORATION
PARAPHRASING EVERY STATEMENT.
WITH THIS REQUIREMENT IN
TEACHER CREDIT ATION EDUCATORS
WILL BE HELD TO A HIGHER
STANDARD. FEEL MATURE THE
RELATIONAL AND INTERPERSONAL
SKILLS AND THAT'S BE ABLE TO
RIDE INCLUDES ENVIRONMENT FOR
ALL STE. AS A RESULT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW. DID IN
SAFE AT SCHOOL WE CAN EXPECT
STUDENTS TO DRIVE IN THE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY KNOW
THEY DO NOT FEEL UNDERSTOOD.
THISOPPOSE A WOULD EVENTUALLY
DECREASE CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
HATE SPEECH IN BOWLING AS WELL
AS WORK TO ELIMINATE THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE AMONG
ETHNICALLY DIFFERENT STUDENTS A
PRIMARY GOAL OF GOVERNOR NEW
SET AND SUPER. THURMAN
ULTIMATELY STUDENTS TO FEEL
MORE MOTIVATED TO ATTEND SCHOOL
AND CONTINUE LEARNING RESULTING
IN ADVANCE MAN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY. WE ARE IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY TO SPEAK FOR THE STUDENTS
TRAPPED IN A CYCLE OF
OPPRESSION. WITH THE NEW
DIVERSE GENERATION OF STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS THERE
NEEDS TO BE AN INCREASE IN
ATTENTION ON CULTURAL
COMPETENCY. AS IT IS EVERY
STUDENTS RIGHT TO LEARN IN A
SAFE AND COMFORTABLE
ENVIRONMENT. ONCE AGAIN WE ASK
THE LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO ADD AN
INSTRUCTION FOR CULTURAL COMES
REQUIRED. FOR CAN APPROVE
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS
NECESSARY THREE C. PRELIMINARY
MULTIPLE SUBJECT AND SINGLE
SUBJECT TEACHING CREDENTIALS.
WE HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
PAVE THE WAY TO AND EDUCATE.
THEM NO STUDENT FEELS LIMITED
IN THEIR FUTURE POTENTIAL.
RESULT OF A DISK FOR THE-
DEBATE IS THANK YOU. YEAH OKAY.
THERE WE GO UP I THINK I KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS
YOU WANT TEACHERS TO HAVE THE
SKILLS TO FACILITATE DISCUSSION
UNDERSTANDING AMONG STUDENTS
BUT ALSO AMONGST FACULTY FOR
SURE AND ALL ALL SCHOOL SITE
PERSONAL- IS THAT KIND OF IN A
NOT SHOW WHERE YOU THINK THEY
SHOULD GO WELL ESSENTIALLY WHAT
WE ARE. FOCUSED ON PRIMARILY IS
ACCREDITING NUDE. SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT IN THE FUTURE THIS
IS JUST ONE. OF A LARGE ISSUE
SO THIS IS THE WAY THAT WE
APPROACHED IT SO IN THE FUTURE
WE ARE HOPING TO EXTEND TO NOT
ONLY ADMINISTRATION AND
FACULTY. BUT ALSO SUBSTITUTE
SOME LONG TERM SUBSTITUTES AS
WELL. OKAY AND THEN I. DO WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT CALIFORNIA IS
ALREADY TAKING KIND OF STAFF OF
THIS I THINK WHAT YOU'RE-
SEEKING TO DO IS REBOOT THIS-
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO GIVE OR
TAKE TWENTY FIVE. SOMEWHERE IN
THERE CALIFORNIA DEVELOP THE
CLASS THE- BIG WE CALL THE CLAD
CREDENTIAL IS THE CROSS
CULTURAL LANGUAGE ACQUISITION
AND DEVELOPMENT. CREDENTIAL
RIGHT I HAVE ONE WARY AND IT
WASN'T JUST ABOUT. YOU KNOW GEE
HOW DO YOU TEACH. AND HOW DO
YOU DEAL STUDENT BEHAVIOR
EXETER WAS ALSO ABOUT-
FERMENTING SOME CROSS CULTURAL
UNDERSTANDING BUILT INTO THE
CREDENTIAL ALSO OF SOME
LANGUAGE ACQUISITION AND
DEVELOPMENT. BECAUSE SAYS
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION CHANGE
SO HAS OUR OUR OUR LANGUAGES.
AND OUR NEED TO ADDRESS.
STUDENTS ABILITY TO IT TOOK TO
ACQUIRE LANGUAGE A CLASSROOM
SETTING SAYS TEACHERS NEED THE
NEED THE SKILLS SO I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS CALIFORNIA
NAME MAYBE NEEDS TO. TO REBOOT
THAT SOME THINGS TO THINK ABOUT
IS IT'S ALREADY DIFFICULT TO
BECOME A TEACHER. MARTIN AND
EXPENSIVE. TO GET THAT
CREDENTIAL YOU GO FOR YEARS AND
THEN YOU GO ANOTHER YEAR. MORE
CREDENTIALED IS PRETTY
EXPENSIVE TO OBTAIN PRETTY
CUMBERSOME TAKES A LOT OF TIME
ON A CLASSES THEN YOU DO THE-
YOU KNOW YOU DO THE STUDENT
TEACHING AND- TO HOLD A JOB
REALLY WHEN YOU'RE DOING THAT
SO IT'S PRETTY TOUGH ENTRY TO
GET. TO BECOME A TEACHER. SO
JUST THINK GEE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING WE COULD REMOVE TO.
SECOND ASK YOU TO POINT OUT
ANYTHING TODAY. BUT IS THERE
SOMETHING WE CAN REMOVE. FROM
THE- FROM THE CREDENTIALING
EXPERIENCE THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT TO. TO
MAKE YOUR YOUR PROPOSITION. A
MORE VIABLE BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
A LITTLE BIT LEERY OF YOUR
SOMETIMES OF JUST ADDING MORE
THINGS ON. WE'RE NOT TAKING
THINGS OFF THAT MAYBE AREN'T SO
RELEVANT TODAY. THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING ON. I ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO THINK ABOUT- AND WHAT WE
HAVE IS WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHING CREDENTIALING. AND
WHAT LEGISLATURE THROUGH A BILL
LIKE THIS WILL PROBABLY DO. YOU
COULD DO A COUPLE DIFFERENT
WAYS WE WERE DIRECT THEM. MAYBE
TO DEVELOP. AN ADVANCED
CREDENTIAL LORD ENHANCE
CREDENTIAL OR REBUILT. THE
EXISTING CREDENTIAL TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU NEED. WE
WOULD HAND IT OFF TO THEM I
DON'T THINK MAYBE I SHOULD LOOK
OVERSTAFFED I DON'T THINK WE
TRYING TO THAT NECESSARILY HERE
WITHIN THIS BODY AS MUCH AS WE
GIVE THEM THE TASK. BECAUSE
THEY TEND TO BE MORE HAVE MORE
EXPERTISE IN THE HUNDRED TWENTY
MEMBERS HERE. ON ON ON
CREDENTIALING IN THE CLASS IS
NEEDED AND- YOU DON'T ALWAYS
WANT THE LEGISLATURE DESIGNED
THINGS LIKE THAT BECAUSE YOU
NEVER KNOW. WHAT IT WILL LOOK
LIKE TRUST ME US WITH THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD JOB
AND- I DON'T OUR CARS RESIDENT.
AT THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF THINK THAT.
EVERY EVERY POINT YOU MAY IS
RIGHT ON POINT AND I THINK THE
CHAIR HAD A- OF. A GOOD
SUGGESTION IN THAT THERE ARE IF
THERE'S ALREADY SOMETHING IN
PLACE OFTENTIMES SPECIALLY WAS
BEEN AROUND FOR TWENTY YEARS.
THERE'S ALWAYS OPPORTUNITIES
REVISE IT TO REFRESH IT.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE IN- AND
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
STUDENTS ARE GOING THROUGH NOW
THAT THEY WEREN'T GOING THROUGH
TWENTY YEARS AGO AND- BUT
TEACHERS NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
THAT. AND SO I THINK THERE MAY
BE AN OPPORTUNITY- REALLY TO
WORK WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
INSTRUCTION FROM EDUCATION. TO
A WORK ON UPDATING AND
REFRESHING- AND ALL OF THESE
ARE EXISTING EXISTENT IN THE
CODE. AND THE CREDENTIALING
PROCESS- I SUPPOSE INTRODUCING
SOMETHING NEW WHEN YOU KNOW AND
SOMETIMES AS- MANY THAT COULD
BE. A MORE BUT ALSO PRODUCE
EVEN BETTER RESULTS THAN AS
THE- AS THE CHAIRS AND A-
HUNDRED TWENTY LEGISLATURE
FIGURE OUT. WHAT THE BEST WAY
TO DO IT IS THAT IT DOES WHEN
IT COMES DOWN TO GROUND LEVEL.
OF INVENTING IT. IS AT LEAST A
DOZEN ACTUALLY SERVE THE GOLD
YOU'RE TRYING TO. REACH AND SO
BUT I OTHERWISE. THE GOAL WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS VERY
LAUDABLE AND I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION ON IT. AND THE
CAMEL. IS A HORSE DESIGNED BY
THE STATE LEGISLATURE. GET THAT
SENATOR. WELL I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I COULD
SEE FROM THE DELEGATES IS A
RICHER FOR DELEGATES THE
DELEGATES THAT YOU HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE. REPRESENTATION I THINK
OF US STUDENT BODIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- SOMETHING THAT'S
NOT. DIRECTLY DIRECTLY RELATED
TO YOUR PROPOSAL BUT WE ARE- WE
ARE IN THIS COUNTRY AND IN THE
STATE STRUGGLING WITH THE FACT
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN BUILT IN
BIASES- EITHER ON THE BASIS OF
FAITH OR ON THE BIG BASES OF
ETHNICITY OR WHERE YOU WERE
BORN. AND THIS NATION HAS BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH THAT SINCE ITS
INCEPTION- AND WE'RE ALWAYS
TRYING T FIGURE OUT HOW WE
SHOULD ALWAYS BE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE REMIND
OURSELVES THAT WE ARE A NATION
OF DIVERSITY NOT OF ONE RACE OR
NOT OF ONE FAITH- WE'VE HAD BIG
DEBATES APPEAR. OVER ETHNIC
STUDIES AS A WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE LEARNS ABOUT
HISTORY TO HISTORY AND- WHAT IT
HAS TAKEN FOR PEOPLE'S FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD TO COME HERE.
AND. AND ADOPT THIS NATION
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD- SO
IT'S ALWAYS IT'S BEEN AN ISSUE
HERE I'VE ONLY BEEN HERE YEAR
BUT I'VE ALREADY SEEN- THE
DEBATES AROUND IT- THIS IS
ANOTHER WAY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE. BY MAKING SURE THAT
TEACHERS ARE- CONTINUOUSLY. THE
SAY UPGRADED OR UPDATED- AND
REMINDED- BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT EVERYONE STUDENTS YOUR AGE
YOUNGER. IF YOU WANT TO BE A-
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL SHOULD THOSE
BE REQUIREMENTS SO. I URGE YOU
TO STAY CONNECTED TO THAT
BROADER DEBATE AS WELL AS A
VERY SPECIFIC PROPOSAL THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE MAKING YOUR RIGHT
NOW AND I. SALUTE YOU AND THANK
YOU. HI TO ADDRESS. MR
O'DONNELL'S POINT AND TO KIND
OF GO BACK TO WHAT MISTER KALRA
IF I'M PRONOUNCING THAT
CORRECTLY- WAS TALKING ABOUT-
WE ACTUALLY INVESTIGATED THE CD
EITHER CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S WEBSITE. AND WE
LOOK THROUGH I GUESS IT WAS A
SORT OF TOOL KIT TO ASSIST
TEACHERS WHEN THEY ARE TRYING
TO BE LIKE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
TO ESSENTIALLY TEACH CULTURAL
COMPETENCY. AND WE ACTUALLY
FOUND A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MISTER KALRA-
WHERE A LOT OF THE MATERIALS
WERE EITHER LIKE MISS
REPRESENTATIVE OF LIKE THE
STUDENTS WERE BEING PORTRAYED
IN THE VIDEOS OR WERE JUST.
BLATANTLY NOT RIGHT TO FIGHT
FOR TEACHERS TO BE LIKE LOOKING
AT IT THROUGH THAT APPROACH AND
I THINK THAT YOU GUYS REYES A
REALLY IMPORTANT POINT AND I
KNOW THAT YOU GUYS DON'T WANT
TO GET INVOLVED WITH LIKE THE
LEGISLATURE AND TRYING TO LIKE
I GUESS MANDATE SOMETHING. LIKE
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING TODAY BUT
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE IS LESS OF KIND OF
TRYING TO TEACH CULTURAL
COMPETENCY BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE DAY LIKE IF WE WERE TO
TRY AND IMPOSE. LIKE SOME KIND
OF TEACHING THING IT WOULD KIND
OF JUST FALLEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND I THINK THE RIVER ALREADY
SEEN THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS KIND OF
DROPPED THE BALL A LOT OF THE
TIMES WITH- CERTAIN THINGS THAT
WE DECIDE TO MANDATE. AND I
THINK THAT IF WE WERE TO KIND
OF ADDRESS THIS HEAD ON WHEN
TEACHERS ARE GETTING THEIR
CULTURAL- LIKE ARE THERE SCHOOL
TEACHING ACCREDITATION- TO KIND
OF INTRODUCE THIS CULTURAL
FACETS TO IT I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT'S-
REALLY IMPORTANT. THANK YOU.
VERY WELL PRESENTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE JOB.
NEXT WILL HERE FROM POSITIVE
DISCIPLINARY PRACTICES. IT I
SHOULD IS NATASHA SOSA HER.
HOLLY RIGHT ALL RIGHT IN THE
EARLY FOR FROM FROM A FROM A
TOWN RIGHT THERE ARE YOU KNOW
YOU HELP WITH THE LAST PANEL SO
GOOD JOB. GOOD JOB OR THANK YOU
NATASHA. ALL RIGHT OUT YOU MAY
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AND
PROCEED WHEN READY. HEY OF.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR SOME WOMEN
O'DONNELL- THE SENATE ASSEMBLY
COULD YOU EDUCATION COMMITTEES
AND HONORED GUESTS I HOPE YOU
ARE DOING WELL TODAY- MY NAME
IS NOT A GONZALEZ I'M FROM SAN
BENITO HIGH SCHOOL ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THIRTY AND SENATE
DISTRICT TWELVE MY NAME IS
JEFFREY- IN AT TEN SOUTH
PASADENA HIGH SCHOOL ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FORTY ONE IN SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY FIVE. AND I
MAKAYLA COKE FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS SIXTY AND SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY ONE. WE PROPOSE
A MANDATE FOR THE INFORMING OF
STUDENTS RIGHTS REGARDING
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SENATE ANY UNIFIED HAD
NEARLY NINE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED DAYS OF SUSPENSION
WHICH COST THE DISTRICT ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS DO STATE FUNDING BEING
LARGELY BASED UPON ATTENDANCE.
FROM THIS IT IS UNDERSTOOD BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
SUSPENSIONS ARE NO WAY HELPING
SCHOOLS. AS SAID IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN BY FORMER US
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION DUNCAN.
THE NEED TO RETHINK AND
REDESIGN SCHOOL DISCIPLINE
PRACTICES IS LONG OVERDUE. TOO
MANY SCHOOLS RESORT TO QUICKLY
TO EXCLUSIONARY DISCIPLINE EVEN
FOR MINOR MISS BEHAVIORS. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE
THIS ONE LC UP OF CREATED PARTY
SEVEN IN TWENTY THIRTEEN TO IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. IT'S STRONGLY
RECOMMENDS TO SCHOOLS TO
INVOLVE STUDENTS IN
DISCIPLINARY POLICIES. AND
PRACTICES TO BUILD A SENSE OF
OWNERSHIP THROUGH POSITIVE
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPPORTS RESTORATIVE PRACTICES
AND YOUTH COURT. UNDER THE LC
FF RECOMMENDATION FROM TWENTY
TWELVE TO TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
NUMBER OF INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS
LOST A SUSPENSIONS DROPPED
FORTY SIX POINT 1% THUS THE
STATE HAS RECOGNIZED IMPROVING
THAT POSITIVE DISCIPLINARY
PRACTICES ARE EFFECTIVE AND
NECESSARY TO REFORMING
DISCIPLINE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION HAS
PREVIOUSLY REFERENCED SANTA ANA
SANTA ANA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT RECEIVED A GRANT FROM
THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS SINCE INVEST IN
WITHIN THREE MILLION DOLLARS
INTO RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AS
WELL AS RELATED PROGRAMS. AS A
RESULT THE DISTRICTS SAUCES
PENSION RESTRUCTURE 75% IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS. SUSPENSION
RATES HOWEVER ARE ONLY
QUANTITATIVE MEASURES OF THE
PUNISHMENT AND THEREFORE STILL
PART OF THE PUNITIVE SYSTEM IT
DOES NOT ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
SCHOOL CULTURE IN ITS ENTIRETY.
SUSPENSION RATES HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASED BUT AS
A WHOLE WE FEEL THAT THE KEY
ISSUE IS NOT TANGIBLE
STATISTICS OR RATHER LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF SCHOOL
DISPLACES THEM WITH THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY BEING DISCIPLINED THE
STUDENTS. WE OTHER STUDENT
ADVISORY BOARD ON LEGISLATION
ROOT PROBLEM THAT NEGATIVE IN
PUNITIVE DISCIPLINE HAS BECOME
SO NORMALIZED INGRAINED INTO
SOCIETY THAT THEY CREATE A
SCHOOL CULTURE WHERE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE SYSTEM OUR
KNOWLEDGE. YET CONTINUE TO BE
PERPETUATED. WE AS A TEAM
PROPOSED THAT PRIOR TO ANY
DISCIPLINARY ACTION TAKEN A
LIST OF STUDENTS RIGHTS MUST BE
READ TO STUDENTS IN GRADES SIX
THROUGH TWELVE. IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO BE INFORMED OF THE
DISCIPLINARY PRACTICES OF THAT
SPECIFIC SCHOOL. THIS LIST MUST
BE CULTURALLY RELEVANT AND AGE
APPROPRIATE. BE READ BY A THIRD
PARTY SUCH AS A COUNSELOR IN A
PRIVATE SETTING. INCLUDE THAT
MINERS CAN HAVE A PARENT
GUARDIAN PRESENT. DURING THESE
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AND THAT
THE STUDENT HAS A RIGHT TO A
TRANSLATOR IF UNABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHTS. AND
COULD CITIZENS FOR RIGHTS ARE
INCLUDED IN OUR PROPOSAL. TO
FURTHER STUDENT UNDERSTANDING.
THESE POLICIES WILL BE
PUBLICIZED ON THE SCHOOL
WEBSITE AND INFORM OF POSTERS
DISPLAYED AROUND THE SCHOOL
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS WERE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION IS USUALLY
TAKEN. SUCH AS COUNSELOR
PSYCHOLOGIST AND ADMINISTRATORS
OFFICES OURTEAM DETAILED HOW
GAS IN THIS UNDERSTANDING OUR
MAJOR THEME IN THAN JUSTICES
WITHIN OUR THEIR OWN DESPAIR
ASSISTANCE. IN MANY SCHOOLS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA OUR DELEGATES
EXPERIENCE ON WELCOME
SITUATIONS IN THE DISCIPLINARY
SYSTEM. THAT WHEN THE STUDENTS
SIGNED AWAY THEIR RIGHTS AS A
TORTILLA EXPECTED THEM TO SIGN
PAPERS BEFORE KNOWING THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE PROCESS FOR
THEMSELVES. AS WELL AS THE
GUARDIANS. PERSONALLY I'VE SEEN
PEERS WHO RECENTLY MOVED TO THE
UNITED STATES FACE
ADMINISTRATION AND SIGNED
INCOMPREHENSIBLE DOCUMENTS.
IT'S ALREADY SCARY ENOUGH TO BE
UNABLE TO COMMUNICATE PROPERLY
DALY. AND IT WORSENS WRESTLED
DISCIPLINARY SITUATIONS AS AN
IMMIGRANTS I CAN PERSONALLY
ATTEST THAT LEARNING IN
AMERICAN SCHOOL SYSTEM WAS ON
CRUISING OUT FIRST IN MANY
WAYS. WHILE THEY'RE WORKING TO
GET OUT OF YOUR DE AND
DEVELOPING DEVELOPING MY
ENGLISH. LEARNING DISAPPOINTED
TERMS WAS THE LEAST OF MY
WORRIES. AND AT RISK STUDENTS
SUCH A SECOND LANGUAGE AND
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS ARE
BEYOND STRESS TO BE IN A NEW
ENVIRONMENT DETRIMENTAL
EXPERIENCES WITH THE
DISCIPLINARY SYSTEM CAUSE THEM
TO LOSE THE DRIVE WITH
EDUCATION THERE HOPING TO
PURSUE. IS STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO A TRANSLATOR THESE AT RISK
TEACH STUDENTS WOULD NOT BE
INTIMIDATED AND SCARED BUT WHEN
SAID FUEL WELCOME TO SCHOOL
CULTURE AS THEY HAVE A CHIU
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
POLICIES AND PROCEEDINGS ARE IN
THEIR NEW SETTING. IN SAID IN
THIS CURRENT SYSTEM I'VE SEEN
CLOSE FRIENDS GIVE UP HOPE IN
THEIR SCHOOL SOME EVEN LOOKING
TO GO BACK HOME AND THE
GRADUATE RATHER THAN.
CONTINUING THEIR EDUCATION. IN
CONTRAST AT MY SCHOOL SAID IN A
HIGH SCHOOL WE HAVE RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED THAT POSITIVE
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPPORTS PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS
P. I. S. WHICH WE PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED AS A POSITIVE
DISCIPLINARY PRACTICE AS A PART
OF THE LC UP OF. IN THIS
PROGRAM IT. IS WHO ARE
INTERESTED WITH IMPLEMENTING P.
I. S. ACTIVELY INVOLVE OUR
STUDENT BODY WEEKLY THROUGH
STUDENT MADE VIDEOS. THAT ARE
VIEWED IN HOME ROOMS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL STUDENTS SEE THEM.
WITH STUDENT EXPOSED TO PROGRAM
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO BE ACTIVE
IN THEIR OWN DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS THEY FEEL CARED ABOUT
AND SUPPORTED BY
ADMINISTRATION. AS OPPOSED TO
SUBDUED AND HOPELESS. ALTHOUGH
THE PBS PROGRAM IS NEW AT MY
SCHOOL THIS ALTERNATIVE HAS
BEEN A GREAT IMPROVEMENT
INVESTMENT IN OUR SCHOOL
CULTURE AND CLIMATE. THESE
POSITIVE DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS
SHOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS AND ALLOW THEM
TO LEARN AND BE REHABILITATED.
THIS BILL LIKELY BRINGS TO MIND
MARANDA RIGHTS WHICH WERE A
SOURCE OF REFERENCE WHEN
BRAINSTORMING WHAT MIGHT BE
MISSING FROM DISCIPLINARY
SYSTEMS AS THEY APPLY TO
EDUCATION. WE KNOWLEDGE THAT
MIRANDA RIGHTS CAN NO CRIME AND
GETTING ARRESTED HOWEVERTHE
MARANDA RIGHT CREATED TO ENSURE
PEOPLE WERE FULLY AWARE OF THE
SITUATION THEY WERE GETTING
INTO. SIMILARLY READING THE
STUDENTS THEIR RIGHTS WOULD
REMIND AND FILL THEM IN ON HOW
THEY AND THEIR DISCIPLINARIAN
SCAMPER SEAT. WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY NECESSARY WHEN
STUDENTS OR PEOPLE IN GENERAL
ARE PLACE SINCE IS STRESSFUL
SITUATIONS. BY UNDERSTANDING
THEIR RIGHTS JEWS ARE SHOWN
THEIR ROLE AND VALUE AND WHAT
OPTIONS THEY HAVE AND ARE
EMPOWERED TO DETERMINE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR ACTIONS.
AND FOR THEIR THEIR PROVE MEANT
A SCHOOL IS A PLACE OF SAFETY A
STEVE OF LEARNING AND GROWING.
BY UNDERSTANDING THEIR
DISCIPLINARY RIGHTS STUDENTS
LEARN HOW THEIR WORLD WORKS AND
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN IT.
STUDENTS WILL KNOW THEY HAVE
SUPPORT AND THEIR EDUCATION AS
IT SHOWS THEY ARE VALUED. AND
WILL CHANGE THE CULTURE AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL AS SHOWN
BY THE STATE'S ENDORSEMENT OF
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF POSITIVE
DISCIPLINARY PRACTICES. IN
SUMMARY THE INVOLVEMENT OF
STUDENTS AND FACULTY CREATES A
SENSE OF ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
BOTH PARTIES. THE GREATEST
IMPACTS THIS BILL WOULD HAVE IS
THE CHANGE IN THE CULTURE AND
SCHOOL CLIMATE SENATOR STANDING
LEADS TO EMPOWERMENT SUPPORT
AND SECURITY IN THEIR EDUCATION
THAT WILL MORE ACCURATELY
CHANGE THE STATISTICS TO
REFLECT CHANGING CLIMATE. IN
QUANTIFIABLE NUMBERS IT WILL BE
SEEN AS ATTENDANCE RATES
INCREASING SUSPENSION RATES
FURTHER GOING DOWN AND NEGATIVE
FUNDING IMPACTS TO DISTRICTS
BEING MINIMIZED. FOR SCHOOL
CLIMATE IT IS INCREASED
MOTIVATION AND ENGAGEMENT OF
STUDENTS IN CLASSROOMS SO ALL
ASPECTS OF EDUCATION IS AND
RICH AND ALL PERSONS FROM
TEACHERS TO STAFF TO ADMIN.
BENEFIT. THESE CALLS REFORMS
CAN IMPACT STUDENTS BE ON THEIR
EDUCATION THREE GROWTH OF
DESIRE TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
ENVIRONMENT AND BE INVOLVED IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION NOW
OPEN THE FLOOR TO ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS GREAT
THANK YOU- SO LET ME BE CLEAR
ON WHAT THE POLICY PROPOSAL AS-
YOU WISH TO HAVE A STUDENTS.
RIGHTS READ TO THEM BY A THIRD
PARTY. YES IT MEANING THAT
THIRD PARTY WOULD BE ON NOT NOT
SOMEONE FOR OFF THE SCHOOL SITE
FOR MOVE FROM SOMEONE FROM ON
SCHOOL. SO SPECIFICALLY WE
LISTED A THIRD PARTY SO THAT A
STUDENT IS TAKEN AWAY FROM THE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS FOR A
BRIEF TIME. OF LIKELY MOST
PREFERRED THE THIRD PARTY WOULD
BE A COUNSELOR SO THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY. FULLY INVOLVED IN
THE DISCIPLINARY SYSTEM
TYPICALLY DISCIPLINE IS TAKING
IS DONE BY- ASSISTANT
PRINCIPALS OR VICE PRINCIPALS
DEPENDENT ON THE TERM- BUT BY
USING A COUNSELOR. IT'S A STAFF
THAT IS KNOWN TO BE A SUPPORT
FOR STUDENTS. AND SIMPLY AS A
SUPPORT. IT AND THEN THE ROLE
OF THE COUNCIL WOULD BE TOO OLD
TO DO WHAT EXACTLY THEM SO THE
COUNSELOR WOULD TAKE THE
STUDENT INTO A PRIVATE SETTING
SO THAT IT'S A SORT OF DE
ESCALATION OF ANY SITUATION
THAT MIGHT BE HAPPENING. AND IN
A THE. THERE WOULD BE THE LIST
POSTED SINCE AS THEIR AS THEY
WOULD BE POSTED AROUND THE
SCHOOL OR ON THE SCHOOL WEBSITE
THEY COULD SIMPLY. READ OFF OF
THAT SO THAT THE STUDENTS WOULD
NOW. OKAY I CAN TAKE A MOMENT
TO BREATHE. PROCESS A SITUATION.
ME CONTACT THE PARENT IF I WANT
TO OR I CAN DO THIS OR OPTION A
B. OR C. I UNDERSTAND BUT I
THINK YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS HERE
IS THAT. THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
THE COUNSELOR READING THIS OFF
TO THEM THAT'S GOING TO BE SO
IMPACTFUL AS THEIR INTERACTION
WITH. A COUNSELOR IN THE
SITUATION WOULD BE IMPACT FOR
YOU TRYING TO DRAW CANCERS IN
TO THE DISCIPLINE PROCESS. YEAH
WE'RE OUR MAIN FOCUS IS. SO
THAT STUDENTS UNDERSTAND THAT
IS CONSISTENT BECAUSE IT'S VERY
COMMON STUDENTS VERY CALMLY
TALK ABOUT THE DISCIPLINE
SYSTEM AND WHAT IS HAPPENING.
AND THE PUNISHMENTS AND THERE'S
OFTEN TALK ABOUT. HOW THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING OR
THEY DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR. BUT
THE TH BUT- BY YOU STUDENTS
BEING BRED THEIR DISCIPLINARY
RIGHTS. THEY WILL UNDERSTAND
THE SYSTEM AND IT WILL IT WILL
ALL OF IT WILL JUST PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE STAFF
BUT IT ALSO PROVIDE. THIS
FRAMEWORK FOR THE STUDENTS THE
ALL PARTIES. ARE ON EVEN LEVEL
AND THEY AND EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IS HAPPENING
OKAY THANK YOU THE GUY I THINK.
I THINK THE BIGGER. THE PRO THE
MOST POSITIVE THING THAT COME
OUT OF A MANDATE LIKE THIS IS
THAT THERE BE INTERACTION WITH
ACCOUNTS AND I WOULD ALSO SAY.
JUST COUPLE THINGS ARE ONE
CALORIES IN A MUCH. BETTER JOB
THAN WE HAVE IN THE PAST YOU
KNOW SCHOOL DISCIPLINE. AND I
WOULD NEVER SAY THERE SHOULDN'T
BE DISCIPLINE SOME PEOPLE TO
WHERE WE SHOULD ELIMINATE
SCHOOL SUSPENSION NO WAY. WE
NEED TO SCHOOL SUSPENSION AS A
TOOL AND OFTEN FOR THE SUSPEND
THE- RIGHT TO GET THEM OFF
CAMPUS FOR A FEW DAYS TO LET
SOMETIMES THINGS NEED TO COOL
DOWN ON CAMPUS YOU SEEN THE
SITUATION OR SOMEBODY'S GET
AWAY FOR A COUPLE OF. THINGS
COOL DOWN WE BRING THEM BACK
NOT ALWAYS AND CERTAINLY IN A
VERY IN A VERY YOU KNOW WE
DON'T WANT THAT ALWAYS
HAPPENING JUST SOMETIMES THAT
IS AN APPROPRIATE THING TO DO.
I WOULD ARGUE- SOME I
APPRECIATE YOUR ADDING
SOMETHING AND NOT JUST TAKING
SOMETHING AWAY TO KEEP SCHOOL
SEVEN REALLY I THINK THE BIGGER
POINT HERE- AIDS DESTROYING
THAT COUNSELOR AND I WAS HE'S
GOOD YOU KNOW GOOD. WELL I
WOULD SAY CAMPUS IS THE GET THE
NEED. TO HAVE A POSITIVE
DISCIPLINE PROCESS ALREADYARE
DOING THAT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
ALL OUR- BUT THEY SHOULD BE
DOING THAT WITH MANY OF THE
LAWS IN THE MONIES THAT WE
PASSED DOWN. TO THE LOCAL
LEVELS ME BUILT SUSPENSION AND
THE EL CAP AND SOME OTHER
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE. SO I AM
FOR A PRE SHEET YOUR APPROACH
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. CENTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SEMI
MEMBER SO I WANT TO UNDERSTAND
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE MAYBE WHAT
YOU'RE FEELING AND STUDENTS ARE
FEELING IS THAT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS ALMOST LIKE WHEN A
PARENT SAYS DO IT BECAUSE I
SAID SO BECAUSE I'M YOUR
PARENT- RATHER THAN EXPLAINING
WHY YOU'RE IN TROUBLE I WAS
ALWAYS VERY HAPPY TO EXPLAIN TO
MY CHILDREN WHY THEY WERE IN
TROUBLE. BECAUSE I ALWAYS HOPE
THAT IT WOULD HELP KEEP THEM
FROM DOING IT AGAIN. IT'S AN OF
THE DID SOMETIMES IT DIDN'T SO
I A REALLY AYE I THINK I CAN
EMPATHIZE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IT'S IF PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND A DISCIPLINARY
PROBLEM IN THIS IT- THAT
PROCESS IN THIS CASE STUDENTS.
YOU JUST YOU'RE JUST LEFT
FEELING LIKE YOU'RE BEING
PICKED ON OR WHAT DID I DO
WRONG SO I DON'T DO IT AGAIN-
SO I THINK THIS IS A VERY
INTERESTING PROPOSAL I
APPRECIATE THE TIMEAND EFFORT
YOU PUT INTO IT AND I'M GONNA.
GOT HER LITTLE LATE SORRY ALL
READ OVER A LITTLE BIT MORE
BUT- THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU A TERM OR KALRA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEASURE THANK YOU OF FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THEM THE VERY FLORA
GRANDER RIGHTS BECAUSE I WAS A
LAWYER IS THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
AND WE USED TO. I DON'T THINK
ANYONE. WHAT MATTER WHERE THEY
GO- WHETHER IT'S- AND
INCARCERATE ENVIRONMENT WHETHER
IT'S THE LEGISLATURE WHETHER
IT'S GOING TO A SCHOOL YOU
DON'T RIGHTS AT THE DOOR
THEY'RE STILL RIGHTS THAT YOU
HAVE THAT THAT ARE VALUABLE AND
I THINK KNOWING THE RIGHTS AND
MAKING CLEAR THAT INDIVIDUALS
KNOW THE RIGHTS IS A VALUABLE-
PART OF BEING IN A IN A
DEMOCRACY BEING IN A FREE
SOCIETY I DO THINK THAT- THE-
CHERUB FURTHER- BUT WOULD YOU
OUT OF VALUABLE ASPECT OF THIS
WHICH IS THE DE ESCALATION.
BRING A THIRD PARTY HAVE NOTS
THAT'S A I THINK ULTIMATELY MAY
PROVE TO BE EVEN MORE VALUABLE
ASPECT OF THESE RIGHTS BEING
DETAILED AND THE LAST THING I
WANT TO MENTION WHICH I REALLY
APPRECIATED THE PRIVACY ASPECT-
THE PUBLIC SHAMING OF A STUDENT
AND THE BUT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH CAN FURTHER ALIENATE
THEM. AND THE PRIVACY ASPECT
ACTUALLY EMPOWERS THEM IN IT
AND ALSO YOU MAY END UP WITH
THE RESULT WHERE A STUDENT WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT THEY'VE DONE
MUCH MORE QUICKLY BUT BECAUSE
THEY'RE GIVING THE RESPECT OF
THAT PRIVACY AND SO I REALLY
LIKE THE TOP ONE IS THAT YOU
PUT INTO THIS APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. CENTER
DRAWS A SEARCHER- I ALSO WANNA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE WE KNOW OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. THE SUSPENSIONS-
LED DIRECTLY TO A GREATER
NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE ENTERING
THE. IS LIKE THE PIPELINE TO
PRISON- AND ANYTHING THAT WOULD
STOP THAT FROM HAPPENING I
THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT. SO
REDUCTIONS I'M I'M I DIDN'T
QUITE GET THAT YOU WERE MAKING
THE POINT OF PREVENTION. UP
MORE MORE DIRECTLY I THINK TO
MAKE THAT A VERY EXPLICIT. OLD
THAT THIS WOULD SERVE AS A
PREVENTATIVE MEASURE VERSES
LIKE IN MARANDA IT'S AFTER THE
FACT- AND- I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
IT'S A COMMON THING THAT THAT
PEOPLE KNOW OF BUT I THINK THIS
SERVES A GREATER PURPOSE WHICH
IS NOT AFTER THE FACT OF IT SO
YOU KNOW YOUR RIGHTS AND YOU
CAN DEFEND YOURSELF BETTER BUT
HOW CAN THAT SERVE TO BE A MUCH
MORE PREVENTATIVE MEASURE SO I
THINK IF YOU'RE MORE EXPLICIT
ABOUT THAT. YOU'LL CERTAINLY
WOULD HAVE. I THINK YOU GET
MORE ATTENTION. ON YOU KNOW TO
THE ISSUE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY WELL PRESENTED VERY
WELL DONE GOOD JOB GOOD JOB
THANK YOU AND MISSPOKE. VERY
GOOD JOB TODAY YOUR FATHER SENT
ME A TAX AND TOLD ME TO BE EASY
ON YOU AND YOU KNOW WHAT I DID
NEED TO BE EASY ON YOU BECAUSE
YOU DO A GREAT JOB ON YOUR OWN
HE DIDN'T NEED TO SEVEN THAT
TAXED OKAY. I KNOW OUR FATHER
FROM LONG BEACH GOOD GUY GOOD
FAMILY YOU DID GREAT. YOUR
WHOLE TEAM THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. YEAH. AND PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT THERE. YOU PAY BACK YOUR
FATHER FOR THAT. OKAY OUR NEXT
PANELS ON REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH COME
FORWARD PLEASE WE HAVE THIS
PANEL AND THEN WE HAVE AN
ABBREVIATED PANEL AND THEN WE
ARE. MOVING INTO COMPLETION.
YEAH REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH GRAB A
SEAT THERE. AND YOU MAY BE
INTRODUCED YOURSELVES AND
PROCEED WHEN READY HOWEVER YOU
WANT TO ALL RIGHT GOOD EVEN-
GOOD AFTERNOON TO SEE MEMBERS
OF THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION IN CHAIRS O'DONNELL
AND LEYVA MY NAME IS MERRY ON
IN A PRESS AND I RESIDE IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVEN IN
SENATE DISTRICTS SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JUST YOU
AND I WERE SIDE AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SEVENTEEN AND SENATE
DISTRICT ELEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JULIA CRISTIANO AND
I RESIDE IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FORTY FOUR AND SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY SEVEN WE ARE HERE TODAY
TO ADDRESS REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
IN SCHOOLS AB TEN PASSED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ADDED SECTION
THREE FIVE TWO NINE TWO SIX TO
THE EDUCATION CODE MANNED
DATING FREE MASTER PRODUCTS TO
BE PROVIDED AND 50% OF THE
SCHOOLS IN- OF RESTAURANTS IN
SCHOOLS IN WHICH THE STUDENT
POPULATION IS COMPRISED. OF 40%
OR MORE STUDENTS BELOW THE
POVERTY THRESHOLD ON BEHALF OF
THIS STUDENT BUYS REPORT ON
LEGISLATION IN EDUCATION WE
STRONGLY URGE THE AMENDMENT OF
THE SECTION OF THE EDUCATION
CODE. OUR AMENDMENT STIPULATES
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
SERVING SIX THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE STUDENTS PROVIDE
MENSTRUAL HYGIENE PRODUCTS AN
ALL FEMALE DESIGNATED RESTROOMS
FACULTY RESTROOMS GENDER
NEUTRAL RESTAURANTS AND AT
LEAST ONE MALE DESIGNATE A
RESTROOM. IMAGINE USING THE
RESTROOM AND LOOKING TO BUY
ONLY TO FIND THAT THERE'S NO
TOILET PAPER. PANIC SETS IN BUT
NOT FOR LONG AS IT'S ALMOST A
GUARANTEE THAT YOU'LL FIND SOME
TOILET PAPER IN THE NEXT ALL.
THIS IS NOT THE SAME FOR
STUDENTS WHO MENSTRIE AT SCHOOL
UNEXPECTEDLY. IF YOUR STUDENT
AT MISTY CAME A CLASSY HIGH
SCHOOL OR JOHN MARSHALL SENIOR
HIGH SCHOOL YOU MUST CHECK
SEVERAL MINUTES CROSS CAMPUS.
TO THE STUDENT SUPPORT CENTER
OR P. E. OFFICE HOPING THERE
WILL BE SOMEONE THERE TO HELP
MEET YOUR NEEDS. NOW IT IS A
MATTER OF HOW MUCH DETRIMENT
THE STUDENT CAN ACCUMULATE
BEFORE EVENTUALLY GIVING UP AND
GOING HOME. IN THE U. S. THIS
ISSUE A PERIOD POVERTY KEEPS
ONE OUT OF FIVE GIRLS OUT OF
SCHOOL DURING THEIR MONTHLY
CYCLE THIS STATISTIC DOES NOT
EVEN INCLUDE. ALL STUDENTS WHO
DO NOT IDENTIFY AS FEMALES IN
WHICH CASE THE STATISTIC WOULD
BE HIGHER. HAVING SEEN
COUNTLESS TIMES THE
CONSEQUENCES OF STUDENTS NOT
HAVING THE PRODUCTS WE NEED
NEED WHEN THEY NEED THEM AT
SCHOOL WE FIND THIS ISSUE
BECOMES BECAUSE FOR CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM. UNHEALTHY
PRACTICES SUCH AS USING
UNSANITARY REPLACEMENTS FOR
PADS AND TAMPONS AS WELL AS
STIGMATIZATION OF MENSTRUATION
IMPORTANT MATTER THAT HAVE REAL
CONSEQUENCES ON OUR EDUCATION
THUS HAVING FOR. FREE AND
AVAILABLE NATURAL HYGIENE
PRODUCTS ARE NECESSITY THAT
MUST BE PRIORITIZE. THE WE
RECOGNIZE THE EFFORT OF AB TEN
WHICH TARGETS TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
WERE IN SPECIAL NEED OF THESE
PRODUCTS. WE SEE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS 26% OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AT SCHOOLS THAT DON'T
QUALIFY AS HOW TO ONE SCHOOLS.
AS WELL AS STUDENTS OF ALL
SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS YOU MAY
SIMPLY BE IN NEED OF A PAD OR
TAMPON. WE PROPOSE AN AMENDMENT
TO THE SECTION THIRTY FIVE
TWENTY NINE TWO POINT SIX OF
THE EDUCATION CODE. TO MANDATE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
SERVING THINK SIX THROUGH
TWELVE GRADE STUDENTS PROVIDE
FREE NATURAL HIGH YOU PRODUCTS
AN ALL WOMEN'S. FACULTY GENDER
NEUTRAL AS WELL AS A LEAST ONE
MEN'S RESTROOM. THIS PROPOSAL
WAS SERVE AROUND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. YOUR FIVE REASONS
TO A DOCTOR SOLUTION FIRST
REGARDLESS OF SOCIO ECONOMIC
CLASS. MANY MEN TREATING
INDIVIDUALS ARE CAUGHT WITHOUT
MITCHELL PRODUCTS. BY HAVING
FREE MESHEL PRODUCTS IN SCHOOLS
HE REDUCE THE HUMILIATION THAT
STUDENTS WOULD FACE WITHOUT
SUCH PRODUCTS. SECOND IN
ACCESSIBILITY TO METRO PRODUCTS
CAN LEAD STUDENTS TO UTILIZE
UNSAFE PRACTICES. SUCH AS NOT
CHANGING THEIR TAMPONS
FREQUENTLY ENOUGH. THIS CHOICE
CAN LEAD TO AN INCREASED RISK
OF INFERTILITY CERVICAL CANCER
AND TOXIC SHOCK SYNDROME WHICH
CAN BE FATAL. IN ADDITION OTHER
MENTIONING INDIVIDUALS RESORT
TO USING SOCKS AND OTHER
UNHYGIENIC ALTERNATIVES. THIRD
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF FREE
HYGIENE PRODUCTS IN ALL FACULTY
GENDER NEUTRAL AND AT LEAST ONE
MEN'S RUSH ME WHEN MAIL THAT'S
NAY ABOUT THEM AND KNOWLEDGE IS
THAT NOT ALL MEN TREATING
INDIVIDUALS. IS FEMALE
DECIMATED RESTROOMS WHICH-
INCREASES RGB TQ PLUS
INCLUSIVITY. THE PRESENCE OF
MENTAL HYGIENE PRODUCTS THE
MAIL DOES NEED BATHROOMS ALSO
NORMALIZES ANDY STIGMATIZES
MINISTRATION. FOURTH MESHEL
HYGIENE PRODUCTS ARE A
NECESSITY NOT A LUXURY THESE
PRODUCTS THE TERM AND TO WHAT
EXTENT MENTORING STUDENTS CAN
PARTICIPATE IN SCHOOL.
MENSTRUATION IS NOT A CHOICE WE
PROVIDE TOILET PAPER IN
BATHROOMS OF SCHOOLS IN CAMP
ONE SHOULD BE NO DIFFERENT. THE
STAFF CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZES
THESE PRODUCTS AS A NECESSITY
TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL PRODUCTS
FOR FREE IN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES AND EVEN IN THIS
VERY BUILDING. HOWEVER HOWEVER
AS A STATE WE NEED TO DO MORE
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO THESE
VITAL MEDICAL NECESSITIES
THAT'S WILL CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL BARRIER TO MENTION
INDIVIDUALS EDUCATION. FIFTH A
LACK OF FREE MENTAL HYGIENE
PRODUCTS CAUSES ABSENCES THAT
COULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
AVOIDED IMPEDING UPON A
MEASURING INDIVIDUALS ABILITY
TO RECEIVE AN EDUCATION. THIS
PROPOSAL MUST BE IMPLEMENTED
REGARDLESS OF COST AS FOR
BITING HYGIENE PRODUCTS WILL
RESULT IN HIGHER ATTENDANCE
RATES THEREBY INCREASING SCHOOL
FUNDING AND ALLOW DISTRICTS TO
DESK NAME MORE RESOURCES TO
STUDENT IMPROVING THE OVERALL
QUALITY OF STUDENTS EDUCATION.
THE INCREASED FINDING WILL ALSO
COVER THE COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A PIONEER IN
PROGRESSIVE REFORM MOVEMENT
SUCH AS ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
HOWEVER OTHER STATES SUCH AS
NEW YORK NEW HAMPSHIRE AND
ILLINOIS HAVE ALL RECENTLY
ADOPTED NEW LEGISLATION
MANDATING FREE MENTAL HYGIENE
LESSER PASS CALIFORNIA'S.
FORTUNATELY WE ARE LUCKY ENOUGH
TO HAVE LEADERS MANY OF WHOM
ARE PRESENT HERE TODAY THE REAL
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATES FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. FOR
EXAMPLE STATE LEGISLATORS OF
RECENTLY REPEAL THE SEX SALES
TAX TAX ON TAMPONS AND OTHER
SANITARY PRODUCTS. THIS LONGER
REDUCE THAT RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF HYGIENE PRODUCTS
AS A NECESSITY RATHER THAN A
LUXURY. WE STRONGLY URGE THAT
THIS SECTION OF THE EDUCATION
COULD BE AMENDED TO INCLUDE ALL
WOMEN FACULTY GENDER NEUTRAL
AND AS WELL AS WHAT AND MEN'S
BATHROOM IN ORDER TO PAVE THE
WAY FOR MORE EXAMPLES SCHOOL
BASIS SOME. INCLUSIVE OF ALL.
YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE KNOW OF NO
OR FOR ANY QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. YOU ARE A VERY
TOPICAL FOR SURE. ISSUE THIS
BODY HAS WRESTLED WITH FOR SOME
TIME- AND VERY WELL PRESENTED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR.
WELL. HE DID A REALLY EXCELLENT
JOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD
ASK YOU IF YOU'RE PROPOSAL FOR
LEGISLATION WERE TO BE TAKEN UP
BY. SOMEONE AND MOVED. WHAT DO
YOU WHAT WOULD YOU FIND
YOURSELVES DOING TO SUPPORT
THAT AND HELP MAKE SURE THAT IT
GETS. PASSED AND SIGNED- OFFICE
THE AS WE ALL RESIDE IN VERY-
CALIFORNIA I THINK THE FIRST
THAT WOULD BE TAKING THIS TO
OUR INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THESE THINGS
ARE IMPLEMENTED- AND I FEEL
LIKE THIS IS KIND OF A TRICKLE
DOWN EFFECT WERE WHEN ONE
SCHOOL SEARCH DOING AT OTHER
SCHOOLS HERE ABOUT IT AND OTHER
SCHOOLS ARE DOING TO. ANY OTHER
I'M WE CAN ALSO START AND
SOCIAL MEDIA CAMPAIGN TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND HAVE PUT MORE
PEOPLE SUPPORT THE ISSUE. I
MEAN I WOULD JUST WILL RAISE
AWARENESS FOR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE I LIVE IN
HOPEFULLY FOLLOW ON THE BILL IF
IT WERE TO BE TAKEN UP. IN
FOLLOWS WHEREVER IT GOES. WELL
I JUST SAY BECAUSE AS- AS OUR
CHAIRMAN- MENTIONED- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SOME VERSION OF
THIS HAS BEEN TAKEN UP AND IT
REALLY TAKES A LOT OF HARD
WORK- I THINK IT WOULD BE
WORTH. YOUR TIME AND EFFORT AND
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM- BUT
IT IT REALLY TAKES A LOT OF
CONSCIOUSNESS. RAISING OF AND
IT ALSO YOU KNOW IT'S A
PERSONAL- PERSONAL SO IT IT'S
HARD TO GET THE TESTIMONIES. OF
BETTER NEEDED TO HIGHLIGHT THE
ISSUE OTHERWISE IT BECOMES
SOMETHING THAT'S DETACHED. SO I
HAVE FOUND THAT THE MORE
PERSONAL STORIES ARE WHICH IN
THIS CASE IS DIFFICULT TO DO.
THE BUT THE MORE EFFECTIVE. THE
MESSAGE IS ABOUT THE AGENCY. TO
DEAL WITH IT AND TO RESOLVE IT
SO. THE JUST THINKING BACK IN
MY YOUNGER DAYS- AND YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LIVE IN
POVERTY. WHAT IT IS SO WHAT IT
DOES TO. TO SOMEONE. TO NOT BE
ABLE TO AFFORD LIKE YOU SAID
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THIS YOU
HAVE TO CREATE SOMETHING YOU
HAVE TO MAKE. MAKE SOMETHING.
UP TO BE ABLE TO USE IT BECAUSE
THE MONEY'S NOT THERE. MONIES
THEY'RE BARELY FOR FOOD. SO I
THINK YOU'VE YOU'VE RAISED A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES
CONNECTED TO THIS. MMHM
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
YOU. IN CENTER YES. HAS AWESOME
HAD TO LEAVE NOW I'M HERE
PERMANENTLY. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS UP I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE- WE
HAVE HYGIENE PRODUCTS IN BOTH
OF MY DISTRICT OFFICES ARE JUST
IN CASE SOMEONE WERE TO NEED
SOMETHING AS THE EXPENSE IS AN
ISSUE- TO DO IT STATE WIDE
DOESN'T MEAN IT SHOULD PROHIBIT
US FROM DOING IT JUST MEANS WE
SHOULD BE COGNIZANT OF THAT. I
AGREE WITH SENATOR TO ROSS SO
HAVING- STORIES HAVING-
TESTIMONY IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- ANY BILL THAT WE DO
IN THIS BUILDING WHEN WE HAVE
REAL STORIES AND REAL PEOPLE IT
MAKES SUCH A DIFFERENCE SO
THINK ABOUT WHO YOU CAN GET
WILL KIND OF TESTIMONY YOU CAN
GET- IT'S HIS TO SHARE THE
STORY. OF BIG AND I THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE I REMEMBER
WHEN I WAS INJURED HI. A LONG
TIME AGO AND YOU. THAT SEE YOU
KNOW EVERYBODY'S GONNA KNOW AND
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
TAKING CARE OF OUR YOUNG WOMAN
WOMEN AND THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THERE- AND I THINK
WHAT IT ALSO DOES IS IF IT'S IF
WE OFFER THESE PRODUCTS FOR
FREE- AND THEY'RE AVAILABLE I
THINK IT TAKES AWAY SOME STIGMA
BECAUSE I THINK THAT YOUNG
WOMEN STILL FEEL BAD ABOUT
HAVING THEIR PERIOD- WHICH YOU
SHOULD NOT. BUT I DO REMEMBER I
DID AND SO WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
BECAUSE ALSO SENATOR TO ROSS SO
SAID- YOU ARE FROM A FAMILY
THAT BARELY HAS MONEY TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE. WHO CAN
AFFORD A TEN DOLLAR BOX OF
TAMPONS OR PAY OUR PADS SO WE
CAN DO BETTER AS A STATE AND
NOW WE JUST WE JUST HAVE TO
FIGURE IT OUT SO I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. AND I
WANT TO THINK ABOUT. DEMONA IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE SOMEONE
WHO'S FRONT UP THEY CAN BE. US
SOMETIMES PEOPLE FEEL BETTER
ABOUT THAT THAN ACTUALLY BEING
IN PERSON WHICH IS FINE BUT THE
MORE STORIES THAT WE HAVE THE
MORE HELPFUL IT WILL BE SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING THOUGHTFUL
AND BRINGING THIS FORWARD. WELL
VERY WELL PRESENTED YOU SHOULD
BE PROUD OF YOURSELVES WE ARE
PROUD OF YOU A GREAT JOB. OUR
NEXT PANEL- IS- THE YOUTH
EMPOWERMENT ACT. WE JUST HAVE
ONE SPEAKER ON THAT ONE IF I'M
CORRECT. WELCOME AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. THERE'S A
LOT OF CHURCHES. TERMINAL DONAL.
YOUR WOMAN LEYVA THE STEAM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JASON CHAN I AM SIXTEEN YEARS
OLD I'M A JUNIOR WALL HIGH
SCHOOL IN SAN FRANCISCO- I'M
ALSO THE GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS SUMMIT CHARTER
THE FOLLOW UP FOR ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS- ADDITIONALLY AT THIS
CONFERENCE I FILLED THE ROLE.
OF RESEARCH TEAM LEAD. WHERE I
MADE SURE THAT PROPOSALS ARE
HIGH QUALITY FOLLOW EDUCATION
COMMUNITY TRENDS ARE WELL
RESEARCH AND- ARE TRULY
IMPLEMENTABLE WHILE STILL
ENCOMPASSING WHAT STUDENTS
TRULY WANT TO DO- I'M HERE-
TODAY TO DISCUSS YOUTH
EMPOWERMENT. SO I JUST WANTED
TO REAFFIRM THAT WHILE SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY EITHER HAVE COST
IMPLICATIONS OR NOT TYPICALLY
CONSIDERED. THESE SIX TOPICS
ARE THE ISSUES THAT WE AS
STUDENTS DECIDED WHERE THE MOST
IMPROPER THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROBLEMS IN OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM TODAY. THE ROLE OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS ITS CITIZENS FACE JUST
AS THE EDUCATION SYSTEM SHOULD
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS IT'S
STUDENTS FACE. LIKE HOW VOTERS
INFORMED DECISIONS THE
GOVERNMENT MAKES STUDENTS NEED
TO INFORM DECISIONS THAT THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM X. OUR
PROBLEMS THAT WE IDENTIFY
OURSELVES SHOULD HAVE THE
HEAVIEST WEIGHT. IN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS WITHIN
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND WITH
DOT I WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT-
THIS BILL THAT WE'VE CREATED-
OUR GOVERNING BODY THE STATE
COUNCIL WHICH IS CONSISTED
ENTIRELY OF YOUTH CROFTER THE
PROPOSAL CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT ACT- AND IT
WAS PICKED UP BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOSE RIVAS AND CENTER SCOTT
WIENER- TODAY IT WAS INTRODUCED
TODAY. AB FIFTY EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT IT WOULD CREATE THE FIRST
STATEWIDE ADVISORY BOARD
CONSISTED ENTIRELY OF YOU. SO
I'D JUST LIKE TO START WITH
PERSONAL STORY IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERY DAY I GET NEWS ALERTS FOR
NEW SCHOOL SHOOTING OR ANOTHER
REPORT. THAT AN IRREVERSIBLE
PACE ABOUT THE IRREVERSIBLE
PACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE IT'S
SCARY NOT KNOWING ABOUT MY OWN
SAFETY IN MY OWN SCHOOL OR ON
THIS PLANET FOR ETERNITY. YOUNG
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD ARE
ANGRY. THEY WANT TO MAKE A
CHANGE BUT THEY FEEL POWERLESS
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T LISTEN
TO US THEY SAY. WE HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER OUR FUTURE. AND SO
THE SOLUTION THAT WE CAME UP
WITH IS IT'S HOT IT'S TIME TO
EMPOWER OUR YOUTH. SO THE
SPECIFICS OF THIS BILL- THE
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT ACT WOULD
CREATE THE FIRST STATEWIDE
YOUTH ADVISORY BOARD IT
CONSISTS OF TWENTY FOUR YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM AGES FOURTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY FIVE. AT LEAST.
HALF OF THE MEMBERS HAVE TO BE
UNDER EIGHTEEN HALF OF THEM
HAVE TO BE OVER EIGHTEEN. IF
THE COME FROM GEOGRAPHICAL
LOCATIONS FROM ALL ACROSS THE
STATE. TO THERE HAS TO BE TO-
COMMISSIONERS FROM EVERY EVERY
DISTRICT ARE ON THE STATE. ARM
AND SOMETHING THAT WERE
PARTICULARLY PRODUCT IS A
PROVISION THAT AT LEAST HALF OF
THE MEMBERS ON THE COMMISSION
HALF HAVE EXPERIENCE LIVED
EXPERIENCE WITH YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS FOSTER CARE
DISABILITIES OR JUVENILE
INCARCERATION. THE IDEA OF THIS
BILL IS TRULY TO UPLIFT THOSE
UNDER REPRESENTED VOICES THAT
THAT TYPICALLY NEVER GET A SAY
IN OUR CURRENT EDUCATION SYSTEM
A KID IN SAN DIEGO WHO IS- AND
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT WOULD
NEVER HAVE AND IS IN A VERY LOW
SOCIO ECONOMIC CONDITION WOULD
NEVER HAVE THE ABILITY TO COME
TO SACRAMENTO TO TALK ABOUT
THEIR ISSUE. WHICH IS WHY THE
COMMISSION IT SHOULD BE X.
ENTIRELY COST FREE. AND
ADDITIONALLY COMMISSIONERS
RECEIVE A THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR
PER DIEM TO BE FAIRLY
COMPENSATE THEM FOR THE WORK
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE SO MANY OF
THESE COMMISSIONERS ARE THOSE
THAT COME FROM STRUGGLING
COMMUNITIES. THE COMMISSION'S
MISSION IS TO EMPOWER
UNDERREPRESENTED YOUTH WITH A
FORMAL OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIC PROCESS
AND THEY DO THIS USING THREE
DIFFERENT ARE THERE TOSS WITH
DOING THREE DIFFERENT THINGS.
FIRST POLICY DEVELOPMENT SO
THAT INCLUDES- WRITING MODEL
LEGISLATION. FORMALLY
ARTICULATING SUPPORT AND OPPOSE
LEGISLATION THEY STUDY IN
REVIEW CURRENT DEFICIENCIES
REGARDING YOUTH AND THE PROVIDE
TESTIMONY I'D HEARINGS TO
PROMOTE THE SERVICES FOR THE
EMPOWERMENT OF ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE. THIS IS KIND OF LIKE
THE SABLE FORMAT BUT HAVING A
FORMAL. HAVING A FORMAL PART IN
THE GOVERNMENT THAT'S YEAR
ROUND AND THAT'S SUSTAINABLE
AND FUNDED ENTIRELY BY THE
GOVERNMENT. SECOND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SO NOT ONLY WILL THE
STUDENTS MAKE THE DECISIONS
BASED ON THEIR OWN ASSUMPTIONS
THEY'RE ALSO TASKED WITH
REACHING OUT TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND LEARNING ABOUT
WHAT THEY NEED. THEY CAN DO
THIS BY HOLDING THEIR
COMMISSION MEETINGS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE. THEY CAN DO THIS BY
ENGAGING WITH EXISTING LOCAL
YOUTH ADVISORY BOARDS LOCAL USE
COMMISSIONS- LOCAL USE PROGRAMS
LIKE TEAM PROGRAMS ALL THAT
KIND OF STUFF AND ACCESSING
STUDENTS DIRECTLY WHERE THEY
ARE WHICH IS PLAYED WHICH ARE
PLACES LIKE SCHOOL ASSEMBLIES.
AND EXCITER EXCITER.
ADDITIONALLY NOT ONLY ARE THE
TWENTY FOUR MEMBERS ENGAGED AND
EMPOWERED. THERE'S ALSO A
RIPPLE EFFECT THAT COMES FROM
THIS BECAUSE. BECAUSE THERE'S A
RIPPLE EFFECT BECAUSE AS YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE BEING EXPOSED TO USE
COMMISSION THEY LEARN ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
ABOUT GETTING YOUR VOICE IN
WHERE THE GOVERNMENT IS AND THE
TRUE POWER OF DEMOCRACY-
ADDITIONALLY THE COMMISSION CAN
APPOINT. OTHER MEMBERS BETTER
YOUNG PEOPLE TO SPECIFIC ISSUE
AREA VISOR BOARDS- AS WELL AS-
YOUTH AMBASSADORS THAT
REPRESENT A PARTICULAR DISTRICT
OR CITY OR WHAT HAVE YOU ALL
THAT DEPENDS ON THE COMMISSION
BUT THEY HAVE THE POWER TO DO
SO. THE THIRD IS INVESTMENT IN
USE AND THIS IS A PRETTY NEW
IDEA- IT'S CALLED YOU FLOOD
PHILANTHROPY AND IT'S GIVING
YOU IT'S EMPOWERING YOUTH TO
HELP MAKE DECISIONS ON WHERE
FUNDING GOES IN TERMS OF
SUPPORTING LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT
DEAL DIRECTLY WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE- THIS IS A GOOD IDEA
BECAUSE CURRENTLY THE BUDGET
PROCESS IS VERY DIFFICULT AND
HARD TO NAVIGATE BUT I'M SURE
THAT THE STATE WANTS TO INVEST.
IN PROGRAMS THAT WORK ON A
LOCAL LEVEL A LOT OF THESE NON
PROFITS DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW
TO NAVIGATE THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THEM SO A LOT OF THEM
AREN'T ABLE TO GET TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE STATE'S FUNDS
SO THIS FOLLOWS THE DIRECTION
OF THE- CALIFORNIA ARTS
COMMISSION. WHICH GETS AROUND
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR AND THEY DID GIVE OUT
MONEY THEY GIVE OUT STATE FUNDS
TO LOCAL ARTISTS TO HELP
ENHANCE ARTISTS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE THIS WOULD APPLY THAT
SAME LOGIC BUT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND ALL THE- PROGRAMS THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE. PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY. AB DEAL DIRECTLY WITH
KIDS THAT ARE IN THE JUVENILE
INCARCERATION SYSTEM PROGRAMS
THAT ARE DEALING WITH KIDS IN
FOSTER CARE ALL THOSE NON
PROFITS THEY NEED THE SUPPORT.
AND THEY'RE VERY LOW FUNDED BUT
I KNOW THE STATE WANTS TO FUND
THEM BUT THERE IS THE
COMPLICATED LESS THAT PROCESS
THAT CAN BE OVER RUN BY THIS
AND FURTHER MORE. HELPS EMPOWER
YOUNG PEOPLE TO HELP MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO THAT'S KIND OF WHERE THE
COMMISSION IS OUT- JUST SOME
PRECEDENT. THERE ARE OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY LOCAL YOUTH
COMMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA- FROM
DIFFERENT MUNICIPALITIES AND
OVER TWENTY OTHER STATES
ALREADY HAVE STATE MANDATED USE
COMMISSIONS. THIS INCLUDES
STATES LIKE MASSACHUSETTS AND
MARYLAND BUT EVEN STATES LIKE
NEBRASKA AND LOUISIANA AND I'M
NOT SAYING ANYTHING BAD ABOUT
THEM THAT WAS JUST. FIGURE OF
SPEECH BUT- CALIFORNIA SHOULD
REALLY BE LEADING THE CHARGE ON
THIS WE ARE BEHIND- SO I'M HERE
TODAY PRESENTED TO YOU THIS
PROPOSAL TO ASK EACH ONE OF
YOU. TO SIGN ON AS A CO AUTHOR
TO THIS BILL. DOING SO WOULD
DEMONSTRATE TAKING A CRITICAL
STEP TO EMPOWER OUR STATE'S
YOUTH. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT ALL YOU GUYS DONE FOR THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND I'M OPEN
TO ANY QUESTIONS OR CùNG
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS GREAT.
THANK YOU SO THE ROLE YOU THE
COMMISSION WHEN YOU MAKE- SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE YOUR WAY ON BOTH
OUR POLICY AND GET. AND JUST AS
EDUCATION ALL. YEAH SO. IT
YOUTH ITSELF IS A VERY BROAD
TERM- WE ORGANIZE THAT USING
THREE INTERCONNECTED GOALS WITH
FOCUSES ON SAVING GAUGE MEANT.
EDUCATION SOCIALLY QUALITY
SOCIAL SERVICES WORKER SO MY
QUESTION IS OKAY. MY QUESTION
IS YOU WANT- THE YOUTH
COMMISSION TO BE ABLE TO WEIGH
IN IN IN IN A IN A BROADER. AND
POLICIES NOT JUST THE
EDUCATIONAL BUT POLICIES YOUTH
RELATED POLICY UNDERSTOOD GOT
GOT A GOOD- OKAY I GET THAT AND
THOSE SHERRY WE ASK PEOPLE TO
CO AUTHOR. TELL ME WHAT WE'RE
GONNA SAY IS ONCE YOU SEND YOUR
LANGUAGE OVER TO US AND WE'LL
HAVE OUR STAFF AT IT LOOK AT
IT. BECAUSE YOU JUST AGREE TO
SIGN ON TO SOMEONE'S BILL THERE
MIGHT BE SOMETHING BURIED IN
THERE THAT'S THAT THEY DO YOU
REALLY DON'T LIKE OR MIGHT NOT
BE SO POSITIVE ABOUT SAYING
THIS IS THE CASE WITH THIS BILL
FOR SURE YEAH. BUT SOMETIMES
THERE IS AND SOMETIMES WE LEARN
THINGS OF THE AUTHOR OF A BILL
DIDN'T TELL US WAS BURIED IN A
BILL. THAT MAYBE- YOU KNOW WE
SHOULD HAVE NO BEFORE YOU SIGN
ON TO ABOUT. SO IN THE HEART.
HEY WE ASK SOMEONE TO SIGN A-
BILL. CO AUTHOR BILL LET ME
SIGN ON MEANS CO AUTHOR BELTON.
WITH THEIR NAME ON IT THAT YOU
HAVE YOU GET OVER YOUR STAFF
AND HAVE THEM READ BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE BRAINS OF THE
OPERATION. YEAH AND IN THE- IN
THE POCKET. SHOULD THE
LEGISLATIVE INFORMATION. OR THE
ACTUAL THANK YOU. A SET RAZA
DID YOU HAVE ANY A QUESTION
ABOUT THE- GEOGRAPHICAL
REPRESENTATION. I CAN IMAGINE
THE- THE- THE CHALLENGE OF
GETTING REPRESENTATION FROM.
EVERYWHERE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF THE FROM LOS ANGELES. OF THE
COUNTY OF TEN MILLION PEOPLE.
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO SEE HAVING
NOT HAVING MORE REPRESENTATION-
IS ALSO GREAT I THINK DIVERSITY
AND A LOT OF OTHER. ISSUES SO
IT'S JUST ONE ISSUE AS THE
CHAIRMAN SAYS ABOUT. THERE'S A
LOT YOU KNOW TO READ HERE BUT I
DO WANT TO COMMEND YOU I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT AND I'M GLAD THAT
YOU COME TO CHALLENGE US AND
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT. ON THE
ONE HAND I'M GLAD TO HEAR THERE
THE OTHER STATES AND- THAT HAVE
DONE THIS ON THE OTHER HAND WHY
HAVEN'T WE DONE IT SOONER SO. I
AM. VIRTUAL YOU KNOW THE
CONCEPT VERY MUCH OF. WHAT
WE'LL LOOK AT THAT FOR OTHER.
AND SO IN TERMS OF THE JUROR
OFF LOCATIONS- WE DIVIDED IT
INTO TEN DIFFERENT REGIONS THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED BY THE US
CENSUS BUREAU- SO I THINK. IN
THE BILL LANGUAGE IT SPECIFIES
THAT LOS ANGELES COUNTY ITSELF
IS ONE REASON WHILE LIKE UPPER
NORTH WHERE THERE'S LESS
POPULATION MULTIPLE COUNTIES
ARE IN THAT ONE REGION SO IN
THE LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE WE-
THAT. LIKE IF IT'S BEEN
CONSIDERED. GREAT EXCELLENT UP
SENATOR. I JUST WANT TO SAY YOU
ALL DO YOUR HOMEWORK YOU JUST
CONTINUE TO IMPRESS US EVERY
YEAR- YEAH NO PROBLEM WE LOOK
AT THE CENSUS AND THIS IS WHAT
WE CAME UP WITH- AND I DO ONE
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE AND THEN
ONCE I READ OVER AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO BE A CO AUTHOR SO
THANK YOU. VERY THANK YOU VERY
WELL DONE HE'S COMMISSION MERRY
WILL LIKE IT THANK YOU. I'M
WITH THAT. TWO EVENTS. I WE
HAVE CLOSING REMARKS. FROM.
RIGHT SO OF IDEA FROM HIGH TECH
HIGH- BUT BEFORE YOU CLOSE I
JUST WANTED TO THE WORLD IN A
VERY GOOD JOB ALL THESE PANELS
OF DONE THEIR HOMEWORK- NOT ALL
LEGISLATORS TO- YOUR MANY OF
YOUR CONCEPTS- HAVE BEEN MUCH
MORE DEVOLVED IN THOSE THAT ARE
BROUGHT TO ME BY MANY IN THIS
BODY. TRUE. THIS IS A GUY AND
YOU YOU DIDN'T TRY AND FIX IT
UP ONSTAGE RIGHT HERE OR SAY
WILL JUST PASS IT AND YOU KNOW
I'LL FIX IT LATER- THAT'S ONE
THING THAT HER DRESS PEOPLE
AROUND A LITTLE CRAZY- SO I
JUST WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS WHAT THEY DID- THE
AND THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
WENT INTO THAT. AND WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. I WOULD
LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN COMMEND
ESTEEM SHARES LEYVA AND
O'DONNELL. CHIEF CONSULTANT
FINALLY REMAIN AND LORBER. AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON
EDUCATION FOR LISTENING TO OUR
PROPOSALS FROM THIS YEAR'S
SABLE CONFERENCE. AND I
SINCERELY HOPE THAT FAIRLY
SHORT VERY SHORTLY WE CAN TRAIN
OUR PROPOSALS INTO ACTIONS
IMPLEMENTED BY ALL OF YOU. AND
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GREAT THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU TO OUR. ALL OUR
STUDENTS HERE TODAY HOPE THIS
IS AN EDUCATIONAL PROCESS
HASSLE WAS FUNDING IN THE STATE
CAPITAL THIS IS A FUN AND
EXCITING PLACE ICH OFTEN CAN BE
A FRUSTRATING PLACE BUT THAT'S
PART OF THE POLITICAL AND
POLICY DYNAMIC THAT WE DEAL
WITH UP HERE I THINK THE
SENATORS WOULD AGREE- SO AGAIN
I HOPE YOU TOOK SOME TIME AND-
GO TO OR THE CAPITAL GOT TO DO
ALL THAT STUFF. AND STOP IN AND
SAW YOUR LOCAL ELECTED LEADERS
TO AND JUST EVEN IF YOU DON'T
APPOINTMENTS JUST WALK IN AND
SAY HEY CAN I SAY HI SO JUST TO
SAY HI TO SO AND SO BECAUSE I'M
FROM THEIR DISTRICT THAT'S OKAY
TO DO. IT'S OKAY TO DO THEY
MIGHT NOT BE THE TO THAT POINT
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
QUITE- FOR YOU TO DO- THIS IS
YOUR BUILDING NOT OUR BUILDING.
IS THE PEOPLE'S BUILDING. SO
WITH THAT I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU HOUSE ONE THINK THE STAFF
THE RESPECTIVE STAFFS THAT
HELPED- YEAH I SPENT SOMETIME
LAST NIGHT RIGHT. YEAH BOTH
YOU. ASSN TIME LAST NIGHT WITH
THESE FOLKS GOING OVER THERE
PROPOSALS. AND THAT TAKES TIME
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FAMILIES THEY
HAVE THINGS THEY NEED TO DO AND
THAT'S- YOU KNOW ON THE NIGHT
OF. NIGHT GIVEN TO YOU GUYS BUT
YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW
IT'S ONE OF. RECOGNIZE IT WE
APPRECIATE THAT. AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS IN YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS THANK YOU. AND THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH